Previously on Big Show.
Papa john's Köln.
Löschen auf dem Handy wenn du da dieses Facebook machst oder das andere Teil Cesme das ist doof.
Was meinst du kannst du mir.
Music.
Sein oder Nichtsein das ist hier die Frage.
Ob's edler im Gemüt die Pfeil und schleudern des wütenden Geschicks erdulden.
Buch verkaufen und also ein delikater hatte halt eben Milka-Schokolade,
und übers Wecker gestellt bin morgens aufgestanden.
Picclick da war Apple natürlich nicht so weit wie das morgens ist musste ich halt auf die Toilette.
Das ist scheiße Duden Notebook nicht mit aufs Klo genommen.
Ich wollte ich wollte.
Tschuldigung.
Music.
Hier ist euer neues Fernsehen,
wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut machen oder ja bestimmt.
Keine Ahnung ich weiß nicht ob es bis zur zweiten Staffel schaffen als CHECK24,
wir sind ja eigentlich schon lange in der zweiten Staffel wir haben auch nicht erzählt kommen.
Sondern Bananen als Podcast ja also wenn somit mit live hören so ist ja schon noch mal was anderes.
Weil er weint dann immer schnell die Puste ausgeht sowie auf dem Kongress.
Weil eigentlich der Unterschied gehören die Lacher nicht vom Publikum bei dir höre,
stimmt das hatte ich ja auch noch mal so ein paar Lacher einblenden so habe ich irgendwie überhaupt nicht auf meinem Dings oder Flash.
Doch warte mal das ist aber kein Lachen Golfclub vorhin war nur drei Leute ja das stimmt.
Bitte besser Schlager klatschen an bis wahrscheinlich auch voll mit so gleichmäßig dass du eine Bundesbank Vorstandssitzung.
Ein höherer sagt übrigens Tim du musst den Ultraschall das Gauting Preset von krieschow auf stumm schalten,
alles zu kompliziert Jahreis ran.
Weiter geht's einfach noch mal anfangen,
welcher.
Also hier ist Freakshow Nummer 259 die letzte Ausgabe in diesem Jahr weil danach ist Weihnachten Sport und zwei Wochen keine SMS.
Ist in der Stadt navi in der Stadt.
Wie viel sind 2 Wochen nicht in der Stadt ich bin du bist auch ein zwei Wochen nicht in der Stadt doch ich schon wieso passe ernsthaft.
Das geht sogar nicht zu anstrengend.
Dann könnte ich mein wenn wir jetzt den Hörer auflaufendes hingehalten Rollstuhl für dich ich habe dir gesagt ich habe Geheimnisse verraten,
was hast du im Rollstuhl sitzt wenn man älter wird,
ja nee ist ja aus Vernunftgründen passe ich erstmal in die Lage ändert so dann,
wenn man Glück hat ist ja 90 Minuten da wenn es nicht mehr ertragen kann nur sieht es aus ja.
Wer hat schon ganz gut na ja gerade reden über.
Kongress und dass dass dir Zusendung ist genau da waren wir jetzt gerade genau also jetzt auch nichts Besonderes weil wir kommen ja auch wieder keine Frage.
Aber wird auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Zeit ins Land gehen sprich da ist jetzt glaube ich dann doch was mich ab durch die nächste Sendung,
eingetütet habe ich das nicht schon eingetütet und ist konzeptionell habe ich die eingetütet,
interprofessionell.
Professioneller Amateur nein Osterhasi um solche Sachen auch kümmern ne hast du auf Workflow in Unterpunkte erstellt oder was,
nackte drüber nachgedacht stell ich gerade fest,
nein ich wollte nur sagen das wahrscheinlich der 3. Januar keine Ahnung wahrscheinlich.
Das realistisch ist.
Den 3. Januar schon wieder.
Umriss und fliegst du in Urlaub Südamerika.
Latein Mittelamerika wahrscheinlich bis ganz nach Süden wird nicht reichen und Zentralamerika.
Lateinamerika ganze Zahlen sagen DANKE Kanada,
Trinkgeld französisch.
Okay 3. Januar endlich der Mauer Mexiko.
Ist heute das jetzt muss erstmal ein und wenn dann alle im Eimer sind und Absagen dann.
Dann nicht halt ne total agil aber ich hätte Gesandter Weise ist es glaube ich nach mehreren Jahren das erste Mal dass du fragst mich ob alle da sind sondern ob alle fit sind.
Also das habe ich jetzt so noch nicht gehört von dir na ja ich meine 3. Januar.
Ich meine wenn es danach ginge hätten wir wahrscheinlich diverse Sendungen nicht gemacht insofern können wir den 3. Januar schon anpeilen ja das ist ja ne halt auch.
Sicher dass ich am 3. Januar wieder da bin deswegen ist auf jeden Fall eine Option nun auch da,
schauen wir vielleicht mal auf die letzte Sendung zurück da gabs ein bisschen Feedback und auch so ein paar Ereignisse,
unter anderem wurde angemerkt dass ich dummes Zeug reden ist nichts Neues oder sagen ja du hast reingeguckt in die Kommentare wahrscheinlich sitzt da jedesmal drin nee nein nein nein.
Ich finde das weiß auch keine besonders überzeugende Argumentation.
Ginge hier um diese ganze Arm wird Abend kommen.
Diskussion.
Ständig Leute daran dass man dann irgendwie Geekbench als Indiz heranzieht aber das war ja nun beileibe nicht das einzige mehr als Beweis Indiz ist glaube ich okay.
Als Beweise bitte was beweist dass es schon Beweise Beweise kann man da nicht anbringen bis bis es nicht passiert dann ist es egal mit der Vorhersage.
Aber immerhin also apple bringt ja morgen wieder mehr arm in den Mac als vorher.
Das ist schon mit dem hätte genauso Chip genau mit dem,
T2 Chip was heißt ja gar nichts also ich meine da waren auch schon vorher kleine.
Meine Microcontroller hat irgendwelche Teile drin die SMC machen oder was auch immer das erteilten eigenen Arm machen ist zwar.
Finanz mäßig für die vielleicht ganz gut so in Haus Zeug dazu verbauen und der Einschub der dann mehrere Sachen auf einmal machen kann aber der macht ja nichts für das OS.
Direkt also der Mark vielleicht dieses secure Geschichten machen aber ich finde das so langweilig da kein Prozess brauchen drauf laufen lasse ist das ja nur sondern parallel Dings.
Das auf jeder Ethernet Karte ist aus dem Steinchen auf jeder Grafikkarte ist noch irgendwas also wenn man das so alles rechnet findet das kann man nicht vergleichen CPU ist das Haupt der Rest ist irgendwie was anderes ich habe das auch nicht verglichen ich habe nur gesagt.
Ja denke so dass in diesem iMac pro,
halt wieder ein Spezial Stein auf Arm Basis ist der Hintergrund ich habe keine Ahnung wovon ihr redet,
ja ist also morgen kommt ihr gelangt nur mit der iMac pro.
Vorbestellbar sein vorbestellbar sein paar Leute haben jetzt auch schon bekommen und paar Leute haben wohl auch schon fertig Hintergrundgespräche bekommen so macht sie Mist den Eindruck dass sie nicht so richtig wo sie das alles hernehmen soll,
unter anderem gibt's Verhalten Stein der als T2 kolportiert wird also als Bezeichner.
Und der Inhalte teilt Funktionalität,
die ZPO ein Absichern des Bootvorgangs umfassen.
Das heißt du kannst dann diese Maschine auch so stellen wie gute nicht von irgendeinem externen Medium und es geht halt über find Binaries hinaus war es halt,
starte Crypto cascade Quali so direkt beim Booten sich gerade auch deshalb ganz interessant.
Da wären ja die üblichen Verdächtigen kochen,
bitte über die üblichen Verdächtigen ja die der Meinung sind dass so ja klar dass das ja das richtige abschalten aber dann kannst Abscheu,
also kannst halt irgendwie auf Notar üblichen Verdächtigen werden noch sagen.
Ja das habe ich aber auch schon beim AppStore gesagt dass das dritte Setting verschwinden wird es ist komischerweise immer noch da ich sag ja nur ja ja du hast ja recht.
Genau also die üblichen Verdächtigen werden schreien gehört hoch gemacht zwei Bier für sich auf.
Muss man ein Mikrofon lauter machen nicht mehr durchsetzen kann ich schon zu laut bin ich laut.
Durchdringend das was ganz anderes.
Woran mit dem Chip ich versuche gerade meinen Gedankengang irgendwo hinzubringen ich habe dann auch noch,
am Rande gelesen dass sie wohl zahlreiche sonstigen Controller die Sie schon immer so custom für alle möglichen Dinge gemacht haben mit in diesen Chip reingebracht haben also das ist ohnehin schon so ein,
System was,
Sony unifier ist so Hardware technische wo sie quasi alle ihre Spezial Controller zusammenführen und das macht ja auch Sinn sowas selber zu entwickeln.
Andere wenn man sich so Dinge anschaut wie.
Diese Diskussion jetzt mitbekommen und hat mir das letzte Mal mit dem Intel Stein und dem Minix und so weiter Nenas habe noch gar nicht gesehen nein,
genau habt ihr das mitbekommen Ring - 23 glaube ich - 3 irgendwie sowas.
Also hier sag mir nichts es ist kam heraus.
Das wohl schon auf seit geraumer Zeit die Intel CPUs.
Wie heißt das noch mal Management Engine genau das was ihr gehackt haben dann muss man den Patch von Intel gab der aber noch nicht perfekt ist.
Rossmann das mit Luca.
Okay oder zu müssen Hacker mit russischem Namen ich weiß nicht ob er groß ist aber hatte in Russisch klingende Namen das heißt ja noch gar nichts ja okay aber.
Nicht immer alles gegen die Russen und sowas auch irgendwie was anderes grillen nennt man dann wenn das nicht so ein bisschen ja danke schön.
Ja aber das Interessante ist das halt,
einerseits also sie kommt glaube ich zwei Sachen spielen ich habe gerade Angst dass ich ein bisschen miteinander vermischen und vielleicht auch überhaupt nicht zusammen gehört aber das ist,
einerseits wohl so ist das dieser interne Code der in dem Prozessor läuft,
eine Weile lang auch auf einer anderen Codebasis lief also es gar nicht x86 Code war darf ich Sie kurz unterbrechen ja.
Der Chat sagt sie hätten kein Stream mehr der studiolink Stream wäre noch da hätte aber kein Ton.
War schon wieder nicht Dinge mal wieder.
Okay Studio linker wieder tun und was mit Zähnen ist weiß ich nicht lade darf fleißig Daten hin.
Können Zähne Pedro wieder an,
geht wieder kannst weiter weg.
Du hast aber schon lange bekannt das ist irgendwie so seit ca an ja genau was gibt auch Leute und gerade im Chaos Umfeld die noch ein Rechner haben wo keine Management Engine drin ist weil sie dem Ding nicht vertrauen.
Genau und es hat sich wohl aber auch geändert dass die dass die das dekoteller exekutiert wird mal nicht x86 waren mittlerweile wohl auch x86 ist.
Das alte was ist alles etwas more Debugging gemacht hat,
und das ist das der Code oder läuft irgendwie auch noch an die rivard von Minix ist.
Ja mir nix mehr vor meiner Zeit war for Linux.
Termine im Tannenbaum das Ding genau das ist von dem anderen Tannenbaum der Professor aus Holland.
Sehr bekannt für sein Buch über Netzwerkarchitekturen ich dich ja wie heißt das andere.
Netzwerkrekorder Netzwerke heißt glaube ich auf deutsch gerade nicht mehr,
ich weiß noch dass damals als ich in dem Fach dann da die Prüfung Anstand der Assistent normal Theater ist eine neue Version vom Tannenbaum erschienene neue Version war ganz hin und weg und dann sind wir zu dritt los haben uns das Teil geshoppt,
und jetzt ist es einfach gut abgeschnitten in so einer der Klassiker,
der Computer Literatur damals und.
Der Tannenbaum war damals schon so Anfang der 90er Jahre war schon so ein kleiner wie nennt man das.
Hellseher nee also so ein populärer Mensch da den Rockstar.
Soweit würde ich nicht gehen weil es Dativ steht das Profil für diese Bereich generell ich zu also,
sie liefert an Minox teilweise drauf quasi,
die eigentliche Erkenntnis ist das da sich quasi noch mal so eine komplette.
US Komplexität entfaltet auf einem Level wie sagt sogar so schön Ring -3 sprich wenn es irgendwie gelingt da reinzukommen dann.
Kannst du dir halt alle anderen Security Konzepte in dem darunter oder bzw darüberliegenden Betriebssystem komplett Abschminken weil dann geht halt irgendwie alles schluckt dann dein haltbar Weise die blaue Pille,
oder die rote oder was die rote keine Ahnung weil hier egal and up in Wonderland,
am da fand ich mal ganz bemerkenswert also die ganze Geschichte wird auf jeden Fall komplexer keine Ahnung,
ob das jetzt irgendwie eine Motivation war für Apple jetzt hier beim iMac pro da so voranzutreiben weil ich glaube da wird es auch der iMac pro nicht die letzte Maschine sein,
bei der das so essen wir werden das denke ich mal generell auf einmal was hat das jetzt mit dem also was hat jetzt nix,
welches ist das erinnert die Blume drin und kriegst du erstmal nicht raus also hat er mich nicht raus weil sie halt Teile CPUs halt die ganze Zeit.
Ja so aber irgendetwas haben das erstmal so ein Apple hat ja aber dieses dieser T2 Chip der ist ja nicht.
In der Hauptsicherung mit drin soll es ja ein extra Chip nee aber der zeigt.
Dass sie eine ein großes Interesse daran haben Ihr System Security mäßig auch auf diesem Hardware Level voranzubringen.
Also allein schon dieses wir übernehmen die vollständige Kontrolle über den Bootprozess,
na und lass uns nicht von irgendwelchen Evi Schwachstellen oder sonstigen sowas etwas Altes und du Valais P&O Evi ist ja eine Geschichte auch oder.
Durch was ist der Standard Asus glaube ich von MT-01 implementation ja genau deswegen alle die da ist die Tür.
Secure Boot machen da macht Apple nicht sondern die machen halt ihr eigenes Zeugnis so sieht's aus genau so jetzt gerade auch mal einer noch mal diesen Screenshot hier gepostet so grade man nicht zu erkennen ich suche das mal hier für uns.
Ran also hast ja die Auswahl bei Secure Boot.
Also nicht das Secure Boot was man bisher unter diesen Begriff kannte sondern eben hier allgemein Secure Boot als Konzept.
Default saiful security and shows it only the latest and more secure software can be run.
Dieser Modus braucht eine Netzwerkverbindung ist hier.
Ist wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie bei iOS 10 Installation time steht da noch ne das ist wichtig das heißt wenn du es einmal eingerichtet hast dann nicht mehr.
Ja ja so wie bei iOS halt,
genau also du kannst halt nichts installieren in dem Modus was zu dem Zeitpunkt vom Netz als nicht mehr aktuell deklariert wird also wenn irgendwas deprecated ist,
eine Version für die ist ein Update gibt dann kannst du die schon gar nicht mehr installieren.
Dann gibt's halt hier Medium Security das ist im Wesentlichen einfach designte.
Seit der Code also wenn irgendwie von Apple oder was auch immer die Quelle wer auch immer hier sein darf dann darf das eben eingespielt werden und III Einstellungen los security.
Und was für mich ist das sozusagen einfach ein Zeichen was mir jetzt auch nicht weiter überrascht dass Sie hier aufnehmen weg sind Ihre Hardware in Griff zu kriegen.
Sollte so dieser exploitation area die jetzt in Intel CPUs sich dann neu aufmacht.
Auch als größeres Problem herausstellen was mich nicht mal besonders überraschend würde oder die haben das doch Aufgabe Diesel Management Engine dass du das genauso zeigen der berichten darüber los dann kam mir eine Weile später von Intel der riesengroße Patch ja das alles nicht machen sollte.
Noch mal englisch und da haben sie jetzt aber auch schon wieder eine Lücke gefunden nehmen wenn ich mich recht erinnere das wird jetzt wieder so ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel das wird jetzt natürlich immer so weitergehen.
Was heißt das irgend also da ich hatte hat vermisse ich weniger zu tun habe mit was heißt das denn wenn du zwei Chips drauf hast und der eine ist gegebenenfalls nicht sich hier aber der andere schon.
Also heißt es auf deinen wenn Apple das so geschickt macht dass sie im kritischen Buchzustand nur von dem wo sie sich sicher sind das was ihre eigenes Produkt mehr weniger ist.
Das ist sicher ist das ist halt nur dann davon gebootet wird und Möbel wenn es jetzt in Exploit gibt für den anderen an Katja,
einen beliebigen Zuständen heraus ist das ja denkbar dass der kochen kann er im Moment quasi keine keiner mehr Sicherheit dadurch dass du einen insecure,
Secure Boot verhindert Januar in Anführungsstrichen nur das hier kein Betriebssystem überhaupt,
erst Haram geladen wird und dann exekutiert wird,
was nicht in irgendeiner Form kryptografisch abgesichert ist oder eben im härtesten Zustand auch online noch mal bestätigt wurde das ist auch genau das ist was um was nebenan scheinlich enthält dieser Secure Boot Chip.
Irgendeine Art von Flash Drive,
dem dann der Kanne liegt den das Betriebssystem bootet.
Dadurch kannst du dann über den Chip sicherstellen dass der Colonel gesignt ist und nur der wird gebootet und wenn der Karte dann gebootet ist kann der wiederum sicherstellen dass alle Treiber und alles andere auch gesignt ist,
also wieso muss es auf dem internen Clash liegen.
Wie auf dem Internet sagtest gerade dass der noch ein internes Flash hat dieser Typ wo der ganze Körner rumliegt.
Warum muss das sein also einerseits natürlich damit der Zugriff beschränkt ist.
Also der Chip selber muss also der T2 muss ja sicherstellen dass.
Einen schon gehackt sos oder irgendein anderes OS nicht etwas in den Speicher schreibt.
Auf das Fleisch bleibt das nicht signiert ist das heißt der T2 wird die Signatur dessen was du in den Chip schreiben willst prüfen.
Weil nur dann kann er sicher sein dass das was da reingeschrieben wird tatsächlich etwas ist was von Apple gesignt wurde du musst ja so eine Kette aufbauen ja und wenn du dann.
Nur von diesem Flash booten kannst den keine booten kannst dann kannst du wiederum sicherstellen dass du ein Körnerbrot ist der wiederum das gesamte shining von allem was danach kam Kader und Genauigkeit karte ist dann nur so der erste Schritt der cascade lake,
da sollte das ganze Finale Colonel dann um wie in diesem kleinen Steinen drin liegt es nicht der Finale also der Colonel ohne die meisten,
kann Extensions aber das reicht doch wenn du eigentlich nur.
Personal Public Key drin liegt,
Inhalt der Kanne signiert wurde den kann dann der C2 irgendwie einsam Laden und der CPU sagen jetzt hier.
Ja der macht mal überprüft wurde der muss natürlich trotzdem sicherstellen dass du nichts in den Speicher rein tust was nicht signiert wurde aber dafür brauche ja nicht.
Implementation Lied ist asozial also ich bleibe auf jeden Fall bei meiner Einschätzung das ist für mich.
So aussieht dass wir hier schon längst auf einem Migrationspfad sind von dem ich noch nicht sagen kann wohin führt wohin führt es denke ich schon dahin dass es dass wir irgendwann nicht mehr diese Intel CPUs.
Das sehe ich jetzt haarlos auch nicht also dann das hat miteinander nichts zu tun mir ist nur so ein so ein Zusatz Chip der sagt nicht ob das irgendwann mal ne Ansage 2 ja das ja vollkommen klar.
Aber ich glaube trotzdem dass wir hier die ersten Schritte sehen.
In Hinblick auf eine komplett neue Architektur die am Ende auch mit einer komplett neuen CPU Architektur in könnte.
Ich glaube mal dass das Tim Cook einfach da auch so der will halt alle Scheunentore zu machen also für die Leute die der Meinung sind sie bräuchten das dass sie nicht einfach angreifbar sind.
Monster ist das natürlich schon mal ein gutes Mittel wie gesagt ich sehe nach wie vor nicht den den Grund für Apple jetzt unbedingt auf Arm zu wechseln außer dass sie dann halt noch mehr Kontrolle hätten uns.
Eventuell günstiger produzieren könnten und auch schneller Computer bauen können.
Na das will ich auch noch nicht so gut die Diskussion dir wurde ja die wurde ja in den in den Kommentaren schon,
ausgiebig geführt dass das ja nun nicht,
unbedingt sogar man kann ja ist natürlich tausendmal darauf hinweisen dass Geekbench kein allgemeingültiger Benchmark ist das ändert aber nichts an der Tatsache dass halt das iPhone auch in real-world use.
Einfach das ändert schon was an der Tanne da ist weil wenn du sagst das iPhone ist schneller weil Geekbench.
Und dann musst du aber anzugehen einen du Verräter weil JavaScript Benchmark,
also du hast halt auch in real world App auch nicht dass man das mit leider kann so eine CPU und Desktop der Macht hat schon noch ein bisschen mehr als die die deinem Telefon steckt,
z.b. Speicher oder PCI Bus.
Jana und also es ist ja jetzt ist es kein kein Grund ist es ist,
die Arbeitssituation mobil Prozessor reinsteckst und da reden wir halt auch von.
IPad pro.
Da steckt jetzt kein anderes konzeptionelles Engineering von als das was du in einen MC reinsteckst nee ich sehe nur nicht dass du das auch sehr sehr viel Aufwand für ein Problem.
Also in ein Problem reinsteckt dass sie nicht haben weil die Mezzos wie sie sind mit den Intel-Prozessoren sind ja okay.
Na Intel kommt an manchen Ecken und Enden nicht aus dem Knick aber im Großen und Ganzen sind sie ja nicht schlechter als Industriestandard.
Das waren sie ja lange Zeit deswegen sind sie ja von Flegmon sind der Industries Tennet von daher können sie nicht schlechter sein als daher Industriestandard im Sinne von wenn ich jetzt bei Dello dabei bei Lenovo oder sonst wurden Gerät kaufe dann sind die alle in der gleichen Liga.
Die sind halt alle nicht besonders schnell momentan weil Intel nicht liefert.
Ja weiß ja nur Intel gibt es gibt halt keine wirkliche Konkurrenz in diesem Bereich können ja auch ein bisschen komisch wie kann man sagen Interessen schnell was ist denn schneller.
Power8 und ihre Mutter was ist ja es gibt ja nichts anderes das Ding ist ja Doris ist halt derzeit in the lonely aber das muss ja nicht so bleiben nee das kommt doch gerade wieder,
ja aber wie gesagt du versuchst hier gerade ein Problem zu lösen das Apple nicht hat.
Doch natürlich hat Apple die Welt was heißt Leben haben Sie denn was hat Problem die Frage ist euer Einkauf Momenten.
Problem kann auch sein dass sie jetzt einen Vorteil nicht haben.
So und natürlich hätten Sie gerne einen Vorteil sie hätten gerne stromsparende Geräte sie hätten gern besser auf ihren Einsatz hin optimierte Hardware.
Sehr gerne schnellere Prozessoren als die anderen weil das ein Vorteil ihrer Plattform ist und ich füge hinzu sie hätten auch gerne eine sicherere Systemarchitektur.
Und alles was das alles was das verhindert dass man das hat ist ein Problem in Anführungsstrichen Problem nur dass du eben jetzt du kannst es nicht mit dem Mac rausgehen und sagen,
hat nicht nur eine das OS sondern ist auch die bessere Hardware.
Wir hatten auf meine Weise erst gab da mal so eine ganz kurze kurze kurze Zeit wo die PowerPC ist hier mit dem 603.
Da hatten sie wirklich mal die Nase vorn so dass das habe ich selber oder Schrott,
E36 oder wieder c6603 abgespeckt das Ding irgendwie,
Ronny soll aber nicht dass du trotz ich weiß noch die Zeit weil mein Performa hatte glaube ich den 36 compl hatte den 6.11 diese Pizzabox Laptop weiterhin 603,
das war,
also Photoshop und auch Spieler ließen deutlich geiler als das was die Piraten davor gehabt also,
geschafft der PowerPC ist eingeknickt und hat eskaliert vor allem haben sie halt irgendwie irgendwie 5,
nicht engineered bekommen und sind halt on the road to.
Whatever liegengebliebene setze ich bitte Sie darauf sagen irgendwie liegengeblieben 64bit.
Ja aber nicht nicht portabel.
Nicht portabel Negation stromsparend nicht wandelt mobil,
Gigahertz mäßig fest und so weiter ja das war das ging es ging alles kaputt mit mit G5 warum wir alles vorbei sind zu dann ausgebrannt also und dann sind wir auf Insel gewechselt so,
hätte jetzt die PowerPC Architektur so gut durch skaliert wie man das eben jetzt bei Arm sieht so oder so dann über Jahrzehnte hinweg da so eine permanente Verbesserung ist plus eben auch noch diese spezielle expertiese von Apple das ja sagen können wir können uns jetzt mittlerweile leisten.
Unten Prozessor zu bauen der genau auf unsere Bedürfnisse hin optimiert ist erinnere noch mal an das erste R.
Das hatte einen Intel Prozessor den so vorher gar nicht gab und ich glaube der auch sogar nicht angekündigt worden ist sondern der war mehr oder weniger so eine Spezial Variante die Apple bei Intel rausgepresst bekommen hat war schon dein Technologie die später auch.
Natürlich Teil der weiteren Architekturentwicklung war aber im Prinzip war das eine total Überraschung dass ihr da eben so ein besonders stromsparenden Prozessor eingebaut haben der natürlich auch nicht schnell.
Na dann war ich natürlich lang war war war nicht schnell aber in dem Moment war halt das Besondere klein mega stromsparend und auf einmal war es möglich so ein Laptop zu bauen.
Und superflach ist Teil was wir heutzutage für normal halten oder damals einfach nur total Überraschung war und das war auch in,
also das Ding mag zwar in der ersten Generation noch keine besondere kein besonderer Erfolg gewesen sein aber die er.
Die A-Linie war es letzten Endes bin ja auch immer noch happy er User.
Sprich jetzt mal Situation jetzt so vorstellt hier mit unseren.
Aktuellen Geräten eurem bis er dann auch bald mal ausgetauscht werden weil es funktioniert wieder und jetzt wird ja alles gut so ich schätze mal in zwei Jahren so war das Problem dann wieder los,
gibt's wieder welche mit echter Tastaturen wieder welche mit richtiger Tastatur ohne Touch Bar und.
Ja der war jetzt ja,
die letzte Zeit war ja nur noch der Chief Design officer für den Space Ranger wie viel Entenhaus rum Design,
und jetzt ist er wieder explizit chief of Hardware,
design & everybody report to him.
Das mag jetzt nicht unbedingt ein.
Neuer move gewesen sein der vorher noch nicht geplant gewesen ist,
aber könnte vielleicht sein dass er jetzt wieder näher dran ist und gerade dabei ist die Leute einfach mit mit so so ganzen Sträußen von Touch Bars zu ohrfeigen,
ich glaube es werden mehr mehr als weniger als meine Befürchtung das geht einfach nicht.
Mensa Touch Bar ist einfach malen fail also der Touch bar wie gesagt der mir einen total egal wenn das Kind hast du gebe und.
Die Tastatur ansonsten okay wäre dann könnte davon mir also eine Touch bar sein ansonsten.
Und dann ist die Touch Bar in den Sleep Mode gehen und ich wusste auf einmal nicht mehr wie ich meinen Bildschirm die Helligkeit ändern weil ich dieses Ding angeguckt haben möchte.
Irgendwas ist anders irgendwas ist anders.
Gebrauchtes ich geschnallt hat dass diese Touchpen in sleep mode gegangen ist und du nur berühren dann kommst du wieder.
So voll scheiße.
Ertastbar kann gerne wieder verschwinden habe ja noch nicht fertig bei Tastatur Port Situation ist ein Problem gerne als Addon aber die anderen Tasten hätte ich gerne wieder.
Dann hätte ich gerne noch mal beim Thema zu bleiben hätte ich einfach gerne mal so einen Laptop oder Akku dann einfach auch mal drei Tage hält.
Ich hätte gerne das Meer hier dein er vielleicht wird das mit deinem mehr klappen also das 11 soll er das hätte ich alles 11 Zoll er hätte ich gerne in.
Hätte ich gerne in einer.
Und sonst müssen sie nicht senden,
da muss ich dir wir sind eben will sie wollen einmal meinen Strom ran dass man MagSafe ist mir auch ich auf meinen kalten der Stadt,
wenn Laptop 3 Tage hält dann ist das egal.
Ich muss mich vielleicht noch mal drüber nachdenken so ein Adapter zu kaufen weil ich schon noch mal Angst habe dass ich den mal wieder in meiner Dusseligkeit vom Bett runter werfe.
Aber ich bin mit dem usb-c mittlerweile relativ zufrieden hat ein Display mit usb-c laden oder was,
ich habe schon immer also ein Bescheid ein Apple Display an meinem Arbeitskollegen,
die Nachwelt kann das ja jetzt mal hier für uns auf zeichnen ja Tim has made the claim about the future kann sein dass ich irgendwie über 5 Jahren und 10 USB3 gut findest,
das hättest du doch nicht wenn ich wenn ich bin 3,
SP3 gesagt was PC meine ich usb-c als Idee ist gut aber usb-c in der Form wie Apple das jetzt auf dem Markt gebracht hat ist leider leider leider ein Fail,
das ist aber usb-c sowie Apple das auf den Markt gebracht hat ist USB C so wie es ist.
Nein doch 4 Ports in einem Stecker drin Strom Grafik.
USB und Thunderbolt alles ein Stecker das ist das Design von USB C da hat Apple nichts mit am Hut.
Doch klar natürlich sind an der strategische Fehler also z.b. ist die Qualität dieser ganzen Adapter auf dem Markt halt schlecht.
So ist es irgendwie unklar was funktioniert mit was Leute haben wir Probleme das ist aber nicht das Problem das usb-c Problem nein das ist auch ein Apple Problem weil er ist natürlich Apples Aufgabe ist,
was geht denn da überhaupt Getuschel.
Was ist fertig mit Tusche,
Entschuldigung Entschuldigung hält aufzuschreiben,
aufgrund seiner unfassbaren Vision die Filet,
ja ich wollte das Thema ist auch zu Ende bringen also kurz gesagt.
Ich wette wir werden ein Prozessor Wechsel sehen es wird noch eine Weile dauern alles was derzeit passiert weißt meiner Meinung nach daraufhin,
dass das irgendwie in Vorbereitung ist denke es gäbe eine ganze Menge Argumente dafür und vielleicht habe ich auch total Unrecht und dann könnt ihr mich alle auslachen,
also sag schon du hast recht.
Dass da was neues kommt weil ich bin ja auch der Meinung dass da dass du auf jeden Fall auf ihre Namen ersetzen und so ich glaube aber das wird erstmal nur also die werden sich von unten nach oben ran arbeiten weil ich glaube gegen so einen puls heißt Intel Chip kann ich noch nicht mithalten,
meine Meinung weil das war ich mir auch die Grafik hatte ja auch so was nicht stimmt schon,
aber irgendwie dumm Nachtigall ich hör dir trapsen sie bauen ein bisschen mehr tun wenn dann erstmal Portale Geräte dafür macht Sinn ja genau,
also für den Mac Pro ist halt Arm doch immer noch sei denn sie brauchen N64 core oder so.
Dann kann ich mir das vorstellen dann gucken andere erstmal erstaunt was denn das jetzt ist ja und warum nicht.
Also das sieht so einer Menge der Lage sind das ist alles da also kann sein aber noch habe ich halt nicht gesehen dass alles kann sein dass die Block machen und dann kommt da so eine Nacht,
Vorabend der weiß nicht wie schnell der Laptops verbaut werden kann wo die Intels im Laptop halt dann schon zu viel Strom ziehen und sich das nicht lohnt oder so aber muss man halt auch erstmal kommen.
Mit dem Thema fertig sind kannst du noch mal hier irgendwie den Film stream rütteln oder soll ich kriege ich jetzt Zuschriften im Chat das irgendwie Sexszenen Stream nicht geht.
Ich kann immer stoppen und wieder neu starten aber ja hier keiner mehr habe ich auch nicht versprochen sehe keine Fehlermeldung ja die ist 21 Jahrhundert.
Ist leider noch nicht da super Unterschied der mit diesem.
Die zweite Runde kurz zu Ende zu bringen ist ja eigentlich nur das von Anfang an secure gebootet werden kann weil sonst ist ganze signieren hat man ja jetzt ja eigentlich auch schon.
Nur dass ich jetzt halt hier unterm Arsch du so schnell mal von woanders oder von dem von dem ja Saubermann selbstgestrickten könne guten könnte was man mit dem t2shop dann sozusagen beides abschalten kann sowohl extern booten als auch halt unsignierten kaltstarten das geht dann nicht mehr.
Renato es erstmal Leute ist er ja auch alles durch signiert und du musst in diesem wie heißt dieser Route lass Mutti dieses es.
Securepoint einmal um booten muss um gesagt sein dass ich auch gerade irgendwie so.
Ich hoffe ja also schön dass ihr das haben aber ich finde jetzt so die aufregende Nachricht jetzt auch nicht.
Wollte ja nur was dagegen sagen das ist Dummheit,
schade ich wollte ja nur was dagegen sagen damit die nicht sein darf die anderen Spezies sich dazu nicht äußern wird na ja so Apple dadurch dass sie das jetzt im iPhone lange durchexerziert haben halt auch,
auf auf den Mac so dass sie nicht fast schon hinkriegen die tatsächlich wasserdicht ist und die man offensichtlich auch einfach abschalten kann,
und dann wieder anschalten und dann funktioniert sie trotzdem noch,
ich glaube das kannst du mit diesem mit dieser ganzen Internet fast scheint wie sie war halt auch nie machen können und wenn sie da ne Lösung hinkriegen die echt solide ist.
Dann Hut ab also Decke.
Dann ich denke sieht auch das einfach die ganze Sicherheitslage immer prekärer wird also ich meine mittlerweile ist der ganze.
Security Bereich wenn man mal gesehen was was für dramatische Folgen das hat wenn du solche Maschinen infiltriert bekommst.
Und natürlich ist er auch auf dem US Level noch eine ganze Menge Arbeitslast das auf jedem Level ist der Arbeit zu lassen aber es geht halt in zunehmendem Maße auch in Hindi Hardware rein.
Da muss man jetzt irgendwie auch die Türen zu machen können.
Gut dass wir das ab würde auch sagen wir uns noch mal vorstellen oder meinst du Freitag machen.
Ja aber das ist immer so arroganten immer nur das zu erkennen und zu ihr alle meine Stimme,
der gerade geredet hat also das mit dem Einstellen das ist Tim hallo Tim Hallo Dennis zwei zu meiner Rechten hier direkt meine rechtmäßige Lette Spaghetti.
Keine Namen für mich werden immer kreativer aber immerhin was du nicht mehr Lotti kann ich mir ja auch merken also das gehört,
dann zwei zu meiner Linken ist der Ronny Hallo Abend,
mit dem face ID nicht klarkommt sag da vorhin mit mir nicht klar oder so rum denn face-to-face,
weil man sich am Gesicht rumspielt hat er gesagt und hier zu meiner Linken direkt ist hier unsere sogenannte Stimme der Jugend der OP,
lieber arm dran als Arm als instagram,
Bernau Munzel, sondern kommen der Sonnenkönig selber natürlich selber vorbei ich mach das jetzt einfach Dennis.
Der mit dem Rollstuhl könnten.
Er gut so aus Abteilung Kupfer ist Glasfaser,
letzte Sendung durfte der live miterleben wie ich irgendwie auf Clemens tippen offline Telekom webseite starte zw1 auf eine Spritze Back-End Informationsseite und dann auf eine Telekom Bestellseite.
Darf ich das ein bisschen den Eindruck gewonnen gehabt und den auch wiedergegeben das hier irgendwie eine Vielzahl an interessanten Verbindungsoptionen besteht die.
Alle sehr wünschenswert gewesen wären.
Tatsächlich ist es auch noch nicht ganz vom Boot aber das einzige was bisher klar es ist das hier mein normales 50 X DSL sich auf 140 erweitern lässt.
Und das habe ich mir dann auch geschwinde geklickt und.
Ja habe ich jetzt wer mir wird 40 Mbit also 100/40 ne oder so okay und also 95010.
Von 15 auf 140 ja also mein Uplink hat sich vervierfacht das finde ich auch wie auch immer doppelt.
Ja weil ich ja immer noch finde Netze funktioniert immer am besten wenn sie symmetrisch sind gut aber du bist dämlich wird ja schon jetzt deutlich nee also vorher warst du 15 jetzt bist du nur noch eins zu.
Ja sowas halt.
Oder warum bekommt rechnet genau auf jeden Fall schneller als vorher da musst du natürlich dann auch noch mal irgendwie nachdem die offizielle Umstellung war musste auch noch mal gegen Schrank getreten werden hier draußen,
Profil nicht geladen Pipapo keine Ahnung man steckt ja nicht drin aber danach funktionierte ist auf jeden Fall.
Und seitdem kriegst du leichtes Lächeln wenn ich hier so Uploads mache.
19 infantiles Grinsen hatte ich jetzt nicht das kriege ich dann wenn ich dann endlich mal mein Gigabit habe die Glasfaser Prüfung steht noch aus also ich habe da.
Dinge in Bewegung gesetzt die sich vielleicht bewegen aber noch keine Ergebnisse dass du bist keine abschließenden Ergebnisse,
gebracht haben und bin zuversichtlich dass noch was klappen kann also meine Fritzbox behauptet ich hätte 109, 3 Megabit im Downlink und 38.4 im Upland also so okay und was sind jetzt an die Preisänderung,
hallo ich zeige alles also ich zahle was ich da Impressa nicht groß was verändert ich glaube es ist im Wesentlichen einfach noch mal eine neue Laufzeit die damit gestartet ist.
Alarm für 5 € mehr,
Bescheid One 801 ist für mich einfach vervierfachen Melissa plus mal was ist wenn ihr hier nach einer Sendung raus seid,
ja das ist allein dieser Upload Kanal schonmal das was man in der Regel so eine halbe bis eine Stunde weniger Schlaf ich so viel.
Na sicher ich lade da irgendwie mal eben so ein Gigabyte an Daten hoch aber daneben sitzen.
Qualitätssicherung chargespeed in der Nacht was passiert.
Verstehe das hört sich an wie das heißt du kannst schon so mit 8 Megabyte die Sekunde hochladen oder nein,
dein Gigabit Gigabyte ist dann in.
125er 84 bpm.
Bin noch nicht so gut im rechnen halt durch 10 durch Arbeit also 250 Sekunden für.
Habe mich jetzt mehr ja so aber.
RGB-LED VT Megabit.
Präsident Wolfram Alpha ist das was einem dann vor, Fehlern,
Beweis Versand Siegen rodungs und dann will ich jetzt mal sehen was er sagt weil ich bin auf 100 Sekunden gekommen.
200 Sekunden bei 120 Sekunden weil der nicht mitgeteilt ist 10 rechnen sondern direkt mit.
Durch 8 teilt im Ernst diese sagt doch heute richtig gemacht oder Wolfram Alpha.
Es ist doch voll schnell so ein teures halt viermal so lange braucht also nicht viel Minuten sondern ja da hast du dann halt eine Viertelstunde gesessen oder so also hast du,
effektive sag mir mal so ein real hast du was falsch gemacht und dann musst du noch mal und so schnell ist dann doch wieder auch immer nicht und dann sind noch wie andere Dinge also.
Das addiert sich einfach alles so zusammen und ich will einfach mal schnell,
und auch so was weiß ich Online Backup wenn man sowas macht mache ich,
und da haben sich dann mal viele Gigabyte geändert auf deiner Platte was schonmal passiert dann ja mit jedem kleinen scheiß Update von Äpfeln und dann geht's hier damit jeder Sendung die hier aufgezeichnet wird,
muss dann auch wieder Backup durchgeführt werden und das läppert sich halt einfach alles.
Oldtimer the hat wirklich enorm lange gedauert und vor allem Maße,
manchmal reicht halt ein Schuss nicht wann hast du noch wieder irgendwelche Fehler gefunden muss noch mal machen na ja nicht schlecht so oder so wird jetzt noch mal geguckt ob hier auch noch was geht dann gab es in den Kommentaren noch,
einen schönen Kommentar liebe dich jetzt noch mal kurz hier anreisen.
Bericht vom Dorf als stiller Zuhörer habe ich mir gerade den Namen nicht mit dir die Fahrgestellnummer nach okay mal genau.
Aussteller Zuhörer und maximal 50% verstehe des Tech Gequatsche habe ich jetzt mal was gefunden wo ich auch was zu sagen kann.
Fiber to the home er bricht er wohnt im kleinen Dorf im Münsterland und dort gibt es fiber to the home mit 100 Megabit in beide Richtungen also symmetrisch.
Synchron symmetrisch.
Konnte ja nicht nur das Dorf sein eben auch viele andere Dorfer und halt das Unternehmen was das von angeboten hat hat,
okay wir machen das wenn 40% der Haushalte die angebunden werden können sich da um.
2 Jahre lang binden für 50 € Monat und in sanddorf seid so schwierig gewesen 40% zu erreichen Leute dann um die bequatscht werden jetzt gibt es auf jeden Fall hier sind wir alle überzeugt weil.
Das fand ich sehr schön die Formulierung hier und gerade die älteren wundern sich dass sie Häuser mit fiber to the home deutlich besser verkauft bekommen als solche die man nicht anschließen wollte,
da dam da dam genau das ist wirklich so ein Punkt über glaube ich auch in dieser ganzen Debatte schon viel zu selten gebracht haben also wenn du so heute so,
Eigenheim hast du bist das verkaufen.
Dann brauchst du einen guten Stromanschluss und ein guten glasanschluss genau aber wenn die Leute da nicht ihren Induktionsherd.
Ich habe,
egal andere Geschichte 100 Kilowattstunden die muss erstmal wieder abregen gut also Strom aber strom ist glaube ich noch weniger das Problem aber egal ist halt das Problem weil meine,
wer von uns seid ihr so Typen die irgendwie irgendwann mal aufs Land ziehen wollen eigentlich,
ich komm vom Land aber ich hatte das vorhin.
Nee aber ich hatte doch nicht vom noch.
Die Telefonbox beantragen auch vor der Hochzeit der Anschluss wie alle anderen hatten so ein bisschen langsamer das Internet als wir profitierten davon sehr.
Aber bis dahin zurück weil es sei denn also dann bin ich ja ganz bei Clemens also wenn's Schweden das wäre auch Land wieder gut.
Wenn ich im Winter ich würde eher aufs Boot wahrscheinlich.
Also ich kann mir das irgendwie hinter nur so halt vorstellen das muss noch irgendwie harter Winter warm ohne also vor allem.
Wenn da kein Glasfaser ist dann nicht genau auf dem Boot braucht er.
Nee aber nett muss man schon haben was ich würde auch also wenn ich jetzt umziehen wollte und dann sagen hier tolles Haus langweilig und Netz Jan ägyptisch musste mit LTE immer nur sagen ja Katze behalten.
Wobei die Frage wenn man sich ein Haus kauft um Opa zurückgeschickt es findet dann kann man sich ja vielleicht auch die Leitung hinlegen lassen also wenn es einem.
Das wäre das Kommentar wird noch noch weiter ausgeführt haben.
Das erklärt aber auch dass es in der Stadt schwieriger wird eine kritische Masse zusammenzubekommen um es für Unternehmen lukrativ zu machen in Fahrradhose rum zu investieren das ging aber Moment.
Habe auch schon paar mal auf den Tisch gebracht.
Das muss einfach kommunalwirt werden und aus anderem Interesse heraus entwickelt werden und dann sollten halt alle Anbieter angeschlossen wer das ist halt besonders Moorbahn Bereich leistbar gerade weil man eben so eine hohe Dichte hat und dann wird sie die Nachfrage auch geben.
Am gut er meint da fehlt halt so ein bisschen der soziale Druck das kann man anderen aber im Außenbereich hat er noch.
Lohnt es sich aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen nicht auf Fahrer zu legen Außenbereich meint ihr zu Hause anrufen,
Gedichte Hüfte was machen die Bauern.
Jetzt aber selbst darauf Sie erkannt haben dass es zukünftig ohne fiber to the home nur noch schwieriger wird junge Leute davon zu überzeugen auf Land zu ziehen.
Ja wundert sich jemand mehr Bier nicht.
Aber diese Formulierung mit die älteren wundern sich ich kann mir das gut vorstellen das sieht das nicht.
Das dass der Gedanke überhaupt nicht kommt oder selbst wenn er mal formuliert wird.
Nicht nicht greifbar ist dann diese diese Notwendigkeit diese Begehrlichkeit die das Netz macht das dass es halt nicht nur so eine.
Ich will Zeitvertreib ich will spielen sein dass es sich hier um wirklich so eine essen kann der stell mal vor du würdest halt Verhalten Haus versuchen zu verkaufen oder auch nur zu vermieten.
Wo ist kein Wasser gelbe ja wieso denn ist doch im Hof nach 200l wird gedrosselt,
Hochwasser,
ihr Volumen ist auf.
Wann sie jetzt folgendes und sie haben wieder den vollen Druck unter den schauen und wir brauchen doch nur weil du dort nur zwei Stunden dazu zu stehen,
angeblich bin ich dem Judith.
Vergiss die ganze Zeit um welche Dinge auf YouTube bin ich jetzt immer noch gemacht vor dem Ausdauer weg von dem Feld.
Hat mit der Maus nichts zu tun das hat hier irgendwas mit ich weiß es nicht,
und ich dachte räusper noch mal warum.
Gott also wenn die räuspertaste funktioniert dann kannst du mir die Kekse geben genau Kekse Erikson hier klicken.
Hier schreibt uns ein Hallo Freaks wie jedes Jahr als Dank für den tollen Podcast ein paar Kekse zu Entspannung.
Genießen und als Vorbereitung auf eine tolle Zeit in Leipzig aus Frankfurt von Jan Dagmar und Lisa,
dann sag mal dieser vielen Dank sehr sehr sehr gleich eine sehr leckere Kekse gibt es auch eine etwas größere Wunschliste erfüllt bekommen,
bitte lies das mal vor das ist ja hier anonym.
Hallo Dennis du bist der Grund dass ich mir vor viereinhalb Jahren anstelle eines Legos jetzt lieber Bikinis gekauft habe also Bitcoins gestern habe ich einen Teil verkauft,
und auch wenn das LEGO-Set nun dreimal so viel kostet habe ich es nicht bereut danke und cheers also es war wirklich ein sehr großes und Überraschendes Paket also vielen Dank noch mal hier.
Dazu mir hat jemand ein Buch geschickt vielen Dank dafür mir hat auch jemand was geschickt.
Was wann ist das genau,
und aber jetzt kürzlich am Wochenende war das absolute höre Highlights,
ich habe das ja workflowy als Hörer Dank 3000m eingetragen weil war beim Firmen Weihnachtsevent wir sind in die Schweiz geflogen.
Und auf dem Rückflug in Zürich letzte Maschine dann sitze der Schnee 1 und ja in Berlin darf ja nicht nachts geflogen werden deswegen dann,
dass du lange warten auf sein Eisen darin endete das wäre ganz wieder aussteigen durften weil es dann schon zu spät wurde,
dann natürlich Riesenschlange an Deck wo man sich die Hotel Schnitzel holen könnte ich habe dann halt so getwittert ja steckt fest in Zürich,
brauchst Dich dann tatsächlich auch zwei Hörer gemeldet hatten und einer davon meinte dann,
ja er wohne 10 Minuten vom Flughafen entfernt und er könnte mich mit seinem Tesla abholen,
Model X oder Model S bin ich mal in Ruhe vor dem,
Flughafen Eingang nason Tesla ungewollt online,
mit eingestehen habe eine Matratze angeboten bekommen und wurde auch mit selbigen KFZ wieder morgens um 5 Uhr,
30 zum Flughafen zufällig dazu wird die Matratze im Tesla,
in Zürich ein gebrauchtes 2014er Modell geschossen,
so komplett refurbished und alles schick gemacht und neue Garantie und alles und dann wie ganz happy mit unterwegs hatte auf den kleinste Motorisierung mit Heckantrieb.
Und meinte aber so im Schnee und auf den Bergen wäre das überhaupt gar kein Problem wurde besser damit klarkommen als mit seinem vorigen Heckantrieb,
Fahrzeug und war ganz happy und ich war ganz happy und noch mal wirklich tausend Dank für diesen super ja,
Sausalitos,
Armen Kollegen die am besten warten mussten die sind die haben dann im Terminal quasi über Nacht des Jahres,
anderen andere Kollegen sind ja direkt ins Hotel Personen später noch irgendwie das erstattet zu bekommen und,
Cover und Hörer der sogar mehrere Schlafplätze angeboten hat aber es waren dann jetzt auch nicht für alle genug in der wohnt etwas weiter entfernt deswegen es war war so müsste gemischte Gefühle aber trotz alledem das war natürlich da dachte ich echt so,
Karsten wird vielleicht nicht reich und berühmt aber auf jeden Fall hat man ganz gut in der Welt,
na melde ich mich mal mit der kleinen Bescheid wenn Liste auch anschließen dass ich danke ich habe auch mit nachricht ich bekomme einige Sachen auch immer unbekannt zugeschickt da will ich mich manchmal auch sehr freuen wenn ich manchmal endlich immer sehr freuen wenn,
ihr mich noch mal antwortet oder so dass ich danke Stefanie war und Sven und zwei unbekannten Personen die mir einen einen Anker,
powerport geschenkt haben ein paar lightning-kabel Huxleys schöne neue Welt das Buch wollte unbedingt mal lesen.
Ein paar USB-Ports und eine Powerbank ich bin einmal komplett von meinen Urlaub aus mir fällt noch was ein mir hat jemand Pflaster zukommen lassen,
Rasta ja Einhorn Pflaster,
Einhorn Pflaster Einhorn Pflaster in einer Blechdose,
Haus,
bei der ist so ein Einhorn Fan geworden ich habe das vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr unterstützt aber,
aber ja also vielen Dank noch mal dafür.
Ja noch nicht da ich kann mich nicht mehr auch noch mal anschließen.
Verzeichne in letzter Zeit ein globales Anwachsen der spenden,
sondere merkt man gerade dass alle so die Plattform verlassen da können wir auch gleich noch mal drüber,
sprechen.
Also kannst du die Spenden die direkt über Konto Überweisung gemacht wer die finde ich am tollsten weil die so wunderbar abzugsfrei sind sicher viele Leute glaube ich immer wieder mal nicht klar machen.
Braucht er mal zum nächsten Thema auch mit überleiten fast schon ist wie viel.
Hole weggeht wenn man jetzt über Paypal kleine Spenden leisteten also wird das macht.
So dankbar ich dafür bin aber jeden Monat irgendwo ein Euro per PayPal zu überweisen da gehen halt irgendwie mal 39 Cent einfach mal direkt zu PayPal.
Das halte ich für etwas viel so wenn man wenn man diesen Kanal trotzdem nutzen möchte das ist es sinnvoller über 12 € einmal im Jahr zu spenden.
Weil bin auch nur 39 Cent weg ja das hat man prozentualen Anteil und halt den diesen festanteil aber beim Euro besteht deshalb fast alles nur noch aus festanteil.
Und umso höher der Betrag umso sinnvoller ist das wird sagen Sauce.
Wenn über Paypal machen ich irgendwie nur dann so nennenswert sind wenn sie sich so irgendwo um 20 € Bereich.
Bewegen ansonsten ist halt separat deutlich billiger wen das interessiert.
Ja kann auch mal die Aufzeichnungen meines talks auf der letzten subscribed anschauen da bin ich damals sehr ausführlich auf diese ganzen Plattformen eingegangen.
Und unter anderem übrigens auch patreon und.
Was an meine Grenzen Augen und rote Erde.
Patricia haute Sohn Sohn Sohn Sohn Blogpost von Neusprech raus oder wenn Sie Ihr neues Gebührenmodell vorstellen.
Dachte so okay was kommt jetzt war es ein bisschen enttäuscht weil ich hatte mir so viel Mühe gegeben ist das Gebührenmodell von hatten wir werden was bisher schon komplett und dokumentiert war,
du bist so ansatzweise zu verstehen und zu analysieren.
Wird ändern sich schon wieder alles analysieren analysieren Sie auf dieser und.
Dann kann sie halt erstmal so bold mit Ja.
Jetzt neu jetzt bleiben 95% der Spenden bleiben jetzt irgendwie bei unseren creators und alles toll für creators und craters hurra Hauptteil und schöne neue Welt.
Na ja also das ganze ist und sie haben schon wieder zurück gerollt ne haben sie mir sorry and will not running a strange.
Irgendwoher ich jetzt noch gar nicht,
verkackte eine eine Menge Ärger bekommen deswegen.
Und das ist wirklich sehr interessant geht die haben's also jetzt.
Drücke doch mal kurz sagen weil das war so ein Bullshit den Sie da irgendwie geblockt haben.
Im Kern haben sie nämlich dieselbe structure für ihr ganzes Crowdfunding eingebaut wie PayPal.
Also hast du irgendwie schon gut durchgerechnet und haben sozusagen nur noch von einer Gebühr gesprochen die halt die Leute bezahlen ß,
und aber im Kern ist es halt auch so gewesen das eben wenn sich ein crater aus vielen kleinst Spenden finanziert.
Das dass es dann eben besonders viel Abzüge gab weil eben jede Spende taxiert wird und eben jede Spende auch wie bei Paypal mit irgendwie mindestens 35 Cent sozusagen handelt und ich verstehe überhaupt gar nicht.
Was das soll weil ich kann mir auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen dass,
jede Transaktion immer wirklich so teuer ist wahrscheinlich geht's im Wesentlichen darum people zudecken ja aber das hat sie auch so eine USA Problematik das,
das dort einfach das Banküberweisung System halt real nicht existent ist alles um über Kreditkarten,
läuft und deswegen da soviel disruption passieren kann darüber haben wir da an der Stelle eben einfach ein bisschen besser.
Ich will jetzt mal dann nicht versuchen ja noch weitere Schlüssel rauszuziehen war offenbar ist das Ding halt jetzt schon wieder vom Tisch sehr schön ändert nichts daran für Leute die in Deutschland Patronen benutzen,
alt aussehen geht einfach also zu 90% das einfach.
Einfach gelogen es bleiben halt defacto 70 %.
Über ja aber das ist die deutsche.
Das ist die Situation ist die deutsche Sicht der Dinge genau,
die Sicht anderer Länder ist auch schwieriger dazu muss man eben deren tax ation System,
verstehen aber es ist im Wesentlichen Ali auch so eine europäische Geschichte also eigentlich für alle europäischen.
Länder gilt es in ähnlicher Form auch wenn dann teilweise noch mal andere Steuersätze rankommen aber so dieses default wegnehmen der Umsatzsteuer ist halt generell so.
David sprechen bleibt halt einfach relativ wenig hängen.
Ich glaube das in Ameland musst du die Steuer halt selber abführen dann wenn du dann die Steuer machst ja aber wenn halt aus Deutschland ich bin gekommen.
In die USA gehen und dann wieder nach Deutschland zurück dann hat er schon am Anfang schon mal pauschal die Umsatzsteuer schmal weggenommen.
So was dir aber auch nie auch nicht ausreichend dokumentiert wird das isst du das dann vielleicht in irgendeiner Form beim Finanzamt wieder Geld machen könntest was wahrscheinlich auch.
Richtig gar nicht geht ist auf Ihrer alles eine sehr knifflige Geschichte dann kommt noch Plattform Gebühren dazu dann kommt noch diese ganzen Zahlungsgebühren dazu jetzt ist ja im Prinzip der alte Zustand wieder da.
Das ist auch an wird auch alles sehr wenig transparent gemacht und,
wie bei allen amerikanischen Unternehmen das was du dann halt als Belege bekommst,
zu haarsträubend scheiße es wundert mich dass,
ich wundere mich warum die EU oder nicht Hertha gegen vorgeht dass man USA mal was gekauft online.
Und dann mal gefragt dass du meine Rechnung bekommst Software oder sowas was du da für traurige HTML.
Printouts bekommt wieso draufsteht Dollar 5.
Wie sieht das war's im Wesentlichen soll kannst du froh sein wenn nach der Firmenname draufsteht aber.
Keinerlei rechtliche Deklaration was sind das jetzt eigentlich ist was wie wo wann vielleicht noch abgeführt werden müsste etc ist furchtbar.
Und das halt wie gesagt froh sein wenn du überhaupt irgendwas bekommst und kannst vor allem auch froh sein wenn du das nach den Vorgaben die wir eigentlich in Deutschland haben.
Einfach mal als fertig vor generierte PDF bekommst.
Weil selbst dieses ich drück mir meine Webseite in ein PDF ist im Prinzip schon eine unzulässige Veränderung des Ausgangsmaterials.
Aber praktisch alles keine andere Art und Weise hat das abzuspeichern denen sich auf dem anderen Blatt so.
Trotzdem haben natürlich viele Leute Probleme.
Jetzt mit so vielen kleinen Spencer man ist ein Podcast Land oder was bedeutet dieses die Idee des Micropayment und dieses ich verteile wenig Geld auf viele.
Scheiße schon mal weil gerade so dieses neue Modell von patreon auch generell wie Panier zu aufgestellt ist und sie mit ihren Paywall versprechen.
Na so versteckt doch euren Content und wir verkaufen dann den Zugang dazu das Fahrrad ja so eine winner takes it all Situation,
na weil du hast ja irgendwie die die im mega populär sind die dann relativ viel Geld nehmen und die dann quasi die Motivation natürlich bei den Gräbern senken anderen auch noch was zu geben.
Habe nur halt mit mehr Leuten kleinteilige sind Sachen und alles bleibt frei arbeiten kannst erzeugt wird sich dann ein ganz andere community.
Und Blätter war ja der lange Zeit eigentlich ganz hilfreich weil sie ja dieses Modell auch gemacht haben aber der meint leider nie verstanden dass eben das was patreon gemacht hat auch sehr klug war nämlich dieses unterstützen pro Monat von X.
Mit mit einem bestimmten fest einstellbaren Betrag und vielleicht nicht unbedingt den selben Betrag für alle.
Dass das halte ich schon für ein Erfolgsmodell die hatten zwar am Anfang mal donations aber das war immer nur so hintenrum dann haben sie es wieder weggenommen.
Barney sind voll ausgeführt auf dieses ganze präsentieren von Empfängern,
das macht alles total Sinn also im Prinzip hat patreon schon das richtige getan das zeigt ja auch ihr Erfolg dass sie da eigentlich ganz gut gefahren sind nur dieses ganze Gebührensystem deshalb wirklich hanebüchen.
Jetzt bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob ich das schon erwähnt habe ich schon mal über libera per hier gesprochen,
ja irgendwas davor ausführlich ja da doch voll also sehr ausführlich weil sie habe ich mehr Sender nicht ausführlich drüber zu reden,
ich wurde halt ich wurde halt drauf angesprochen ob ich sie nicht mal erwähnen könnte da war ich mir denn jetzt und wie auf einmal nicht mehr so sicher ob ich das überhaupt erwähnt habe aber wahrscheinlich habe ich erwähnt.
Ich halte dich jetzt mal kurz aber im Prinzip wär quasi auf.
Auf eine Plattform zurückgreifen möchte weil er sie sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht in der Lage sind mit vielen Kleinspenden umzugehen oder keine Lust hat.
Kontonummer zur arbeiten da lieber so ein Proxy dazwischenschalten möchte.
Malibu abheben weil es sieht ganz ordentlich aus und da kann man halt auch so Gruppen aufmachen kann man irgendwie auch mit mehreren Leuten Geld in den Pool sammeln und dann selber bestimmen wer wie viel Geld davon bekommen soll.
Also ein kontrollierter Auszahlung eines Pools machen und außerdem was ganz charmant finde ist dass die.
Abrechnung wöchentlich ist was.
Eigentlich für solche permanenten Unterstützungsmaßnahmen eine bessere Auflösung ist als als monatlich finde dieses monatlich ist dann doch irgendwie sehr schwerfällige Geschichte und das wöchentlich zu machen für dich als App für Fisch.
Na und Libra per ist halt was ich nur Nonprofit-Organisationen.
Und hat mangopay als Zahlungssystem quasi eingebaut also Prinzip ist es eigentlich weniger Rapper um mangopay herum.
Und mich sehr viel mehr also halt noch so eine Verteilung Maschine drum herum und gibt im Wesentlichen die Zahlungsgebühren die halt bei mangopay ohnehin anfallen weiter aber sonst halt nix.
Libra per selber finanziert sich quasi über Spenden an zebrapay über Diba.
Hast genauso einen target wie alle anderen auch.
Brabbel nimmt Spenden an und verteilt sie an Leute die diese erhalten sollen.
Das heißt wenn du da und Viet Huckel bist und sag ihr ich bin geil ich mehr Geld.
Ja damit die auch weiterhin Gehalt bleibe dann kann man dann irgendwie auf Lippe pissnelke gehen und sagen ich will Huckel pro Woche 1 $ geben und sie kommt das Geld und dann,
das kommt dann entweder per Lastschrift oder per Kreditkarte.
Oder,
fort Alamo sagt Konto dass ich voll lade als Spender und dann verteile ich oder muss ich dann genau.
Du musst ein Konto also kannst auch du kannst was ich regelmäßige Lastschriften angeben was kannst du alles sagen,
holt bei mir regelmäßig Geld ab um.
Das Ding aufzufüllen und dann hast du einmalige Gebühren für das Ausführen einer Lastschrift bei Kreditkarten sind die Gebühren etwas höher aber es sind halt im Wesentlichen die Gebühren die diese Zahlungssysteme bzw mangopay,
die das Implementieren ohnehin abwirft und Libra per selber wirft da nichts drauf es gibt auch keine Plattform Gebühren,
das Geld landet dann quasi auf deinem verteilt Konto und Debra Personallage selber das von deinem Bankkonto zu holen oder von deiner Kreditkarte zu eben.
Um den entsprechenden Zahlungsgebühren aber das war's dann auch und wenn die Kohle dann halt auf deinem verteilt Konto ist dann wird sie dann eben an Aldi.
Die du als target als greater target ausgewählt hast verteilt und Chris hat eine relativ genaue Aufstellung wie das dann.
Sich in der jeweiligen Woche verteilt hat und das.
War's dann eigentlich auch schon ich bin noch ein bisschen unzufrieden wir euch vorstellen könnt mit der buchhalterischen Situation aber das Gute ist hier kann man halt.
Das ist alles Open Source essen alles aufgeht aplicom halt im Prinzip auch einfach mal ein Puzzle Quest schicken nicht dass der schon getan hätte aber ich könnte dann könnte es halt um die Peißen Django nichts Besonderes läuft aber eben und wird betrieben und das schon mal ganz gut,
immerhin kein PHP was willst du denn ist immerhin kein Pia fehlst und Duden.
Tom hatte halt dieselbe Kontrolle dadrüber uns halt irgendwie ein faires System also ich finde das irgendwie ganz nett.
So ist das nicht selbst jetzt noch nicht drauf weil ich will also ich würde das vielleicht tun weil ich finde die Konditional nicht in Ordnung ich.
Warte aber noch mal bis ich das irgendwie ordentlich abgebildet bekomme.
Also du musst deinen Lua Script I weiter,
nur mal kurz ein Mikrofon nicht was man Kekse Lasche Kekse Rascheln du hast zehn Minuten.
Hipanema Gronemann.
Micky Maus mach alle alle alle Mikrofone aus gehört die makrone.
Warte Monolog,
das habe ich nach meinem lange du mich noch ja das habe ich jetzt habt ihr mich in meinem langen Monolog unterbrochen.
Was du da anbieten was ich auch gerne hätte ist bei Amazon.
Man kann natürlich jetzt lauter kleine fünf und 10 € Sachen auf die Wunschliste setzen damit Leute da irgendwie was finden aber ehrlich gesagt irgendwann geht mir auch.
Der Bedarf an kleinen scheiß irgendwie ist halt vorbei dann hast halt so dicke teure Sachen und die Geschenke hat sich keiner außer das jetzt mal Glück aber sonst.
Geht das nicht aber wenn Amazon auch mal so ein bisschen pulling machen würde dann könnte man auch mal größere Sachen erfüllen und dann müssen wir nicht so viel.
Die Masse das Wetter für 200 € irgendein dickes Werkzeug oder so das schenkt dir natürlich keiner weiß natürlich sind 200 € viel zu viel.
Außer sie haben mir auch wie das LEGO-Set gegen Bitcoin tauschen dann ist sowieso wenn sie dann für dieses.
Euro 200 € teil und wie sich zehn Leute zusammenfinden oder irgendwie 15 oder so dass sie sagen so hier ist ich,
Paket bei Amazon nicht wird offiziell Euro in was rein genau was ist mir eigentlich egal und dann sammelt Amazon halt so lange zusammen Viertelstunde Sache bis es da ist oder vielleicht dass sie,
Brot Eisdiele 200 würde ich jetzt nicht geben aber ich würd 10 € da reingehen und dann hast halt Brot also so eine Art,
Vogelbaum anderen erfüllt ist immer dann mach's gut,
oder liegst oder selber den Rest drauf weißt du hast schon irgendwie 100 voll von irgendwelchen externer sagst ok die restlichen 100 Zahl ist ja selber und dann habe ich so das wäre die ganze Zeit,
ist natürlich schwierig weil Wer ist haben wir uns mäßig und dann erst dann Ebeling Partner welche Jurisdiktion gilt in dem Moment als schon verstehen warum das nicht so ist auch wenn die Idee sich zusammenzutun der Ansicht,
na ganz gute ist wie soll ich denn jemals das Güde Brotmesser Franz Güde die geschmiedet Doppelkopf Griff italienisches Olivenholz,
bekommen ja das ist super.
Ja weil man könnte man könnte es nicht diese Kickstarter mäßig mit Plättchen und so weiter machen du sagst du bleibst halt auf die Wunschliste soundsoviel und dann wird das Geld zwar noch nicht abgebucht aber du kannst rasieren,
von dem altem auf der Wunschliste New Yorker 50% gepatchte keine Ahnung also wenn Amazon das wollte könnte es durchaus machen glaube ich.
So ist das mutert,
ja es ist gratis Newton sicher einzelne Kanäle das wird sich dann immer auf diesen die Maus ich habe keine Ahnung woher das kommt ich muss ja mal dieses neue Ultraschall installieren glaube ich.
Nein damit sich nicht alles die ganzen weiter sonst noch eine Sache sagen also,
gerade dieser Open Source Gedanke bei den liberating finde ich halt insofern sehr interessant als dass man halt hier mit dem System mal wirklich was pfiffiges bauen könnte was z.b.
was wahrscheinlich schwierig zu realisieren sein wird aber jetzt nicht grundsätzlich unmöglich,
wenn man so etwas wie so ein donation Back-End gleich mit einer fin TS Schnittstelle ausgestattet.
Finde es etwas von fintech.
Finde es ist der Nachfolger von HBCI Online Banking also wenn sich sozusagen Sonnensystem.
Mir gegenüber wie eine Bank Verhalten könnte also nicht rechtlich wie eine Bank sondern halt technisch Spiele Bank,
sprich das Protokoll soweit implementieren kann dass man quasi mit einem typischen Online-Banking klein dagegen checken kann und sagen kann hier mein lieber P-Konto bitte einmal einrichten.
Und du dann eben auch deine ganzen donations entsprechend,
darüber mitgeteilt bekommen also quasi als Transaktionen in einem,
transaktions vermittelnden Onlinebanking Protokoll dann wäre schon cool der kurze Weg wäre wahrscheinlich dann das man halt irgendwie für irgendein Tool weil es z.b. das Porto money money,
aber kann man ja mit Luca auch so Web scraping und sowas machen oder halt auch ansprechende API calls einbauen gibt's natürlich hier passende Rest APIs gegen die man schon sprechen kann hätte man soll Integration auch.
Was bauen billig für das total geil ich will das unbedingt da arbeiten.
Schmatz jetzt hast du deinen Gedanken zu Ende geführt weil mein Gedanke zu Ende geführt,
so und wenn ihr dann irgendwie die Wunschliste von Nuckel Roy dilettieren dann ist der Dennis.
Was ich vorstellen meine Wunschliste,
nein nie wieder alle leer gekauft habt ihr wisst nicht mehr was Sache ist die einzelnen auf die Idee kommt oh mann jetzt habe ich ja gar nicht mehr viel kann gesagt ihr bescheid und wir tun neue Sachen auf die Wunschliste Geschenk Geschenke für eure,
lieben kaufen und bitte auf Amazon vom metaebene.me geben und dann habt ihr dann auch den passenden.
Einstieg in eure Shoppingwelt ja und auch also meine Thomann Wunschliste ich habe gerade geguckt hatte einen Gesamtwert von 42000,
Euro,
Futterhändler wir müssen reden,
direct mal anfragen an das extremtextil keine Wunschliste,
prangere manchmal ärgerlich mich auch dass ich keinen gear acquisition Syndrome bei mir fällt echt nichts ein,
geht immer weiter wenn was runterkommt von der Liste kommt heute neue drauf,
echt was bei mir ist es nicht so ich habe nicht so die Gier nach Nacht nach 1000 Dinge zu Meister der Zeit auch nichts zu kaufen gibt also.
Bei Apple kann man frühestens bei der Jahres kaufen ja bis dahin muss ich einfach nur Rente ansparen,
bei Amazon kann man sogar Nähmaschinen kaufen muss ich gar nicht.
Aber X mit drin ist.
Und achso,
ich dachte da kommt eine Frage ja was nicht vielleicht dass du bei dir kommt sofort und ein Gedanke also was haben wir so viel deswegen musst du mich wirklich ein bisschen antriggern sonst weiß ich ja nicht was ich was erzählen ja es gibt da tatsächlich jetzt mehrere Aspekte die man vielleicht mal.
Aufrufen sollte also was er sicherlich niemanden entgangen sein dürfte ist das so.
Bitcoin wieder so unfassbar inhalt gemacht hat sich dafür haben jetzt gegenüber dem Kuss von vorm Jahr so eine Verzehnfachung so in der Größenordnung oder so also vor einem Jahr vom also.
Ich glaub letztes Jahr auf dem Kongress war das erste Mal wo das so in Richtung 1000 € ging oder 900 vielleicht glaube ich sogar nur.
Inzwischen heute hat sie zu Hause gegangen bin war es knapp bei 14000 also sind schon eher so 15 16 fach also redest du jetzt von.
Euro Dollar Euro von Euro wert ist 65 ist ja egal auf welcher Biro.
Außer das Verhältnis zwischen Euro und Dollar sich geändert in der Zeit was glaube ich auch passiert ist aber egal man kann schon so von 1500 % ausgehen egal welche Währung so ca.
Ja guck mal mal kurz hier wieso der das entwickelt hat von hier.
Bitte digitalyst zu.
Sich Zecken 20 16 was man jetzt immer unbedingt.
Heute hat den schon 13 number,
13 13 12.
Und Otterberg wo steht der gute Frage 775 so und jetzt noch mal wie viel heute was ist der Euro oder Dollar jetzt.
Dollar SFO 775.
Und jetzt haben wir 16170 16170 oder hast keine Verzehnfachung oder.
Wissen vor 20 Uhr warum 20,8.
Nicht schläft, mama, mama was löst das alles aus man weiß es nicht.
Wird es gibt viel Gerede über Tulpenzwiebeln und.
Andere Aspekte der MMI Blase so in Holland Kapitalismus müssen muss genau Fähre,
gibt's ein entsprechend viel Debatte ich verfolge auch nur so mit einem Auge was mir total auf Mama reingeschaut hast Dennis na ja die ganze hier,
JP Morgan die dann immer noch bis vor paar Wochen gesagt haben ja das ist alles,
total mega gefährlich kann jederzeit brechen das ist ein Bubble blubb blubb blubb und dann kommt ja Jappy morgen steigt ein,
also wollen demnächst auch irgendwie den Bitcoin möglich machen damit dran zu zu,
handeln oder wie auch immer dein jetzt gerade letzten Sonntag und wurde,
also das gibt ja diesen Futuremark da kann man da oggi in einem Monat brauche ich Bitcoins also eigentlich gibt's das mit Rohstoffe so ich hätte gerne in einem Monat 3000 Barrel Öl wie der Preis ist ich würde gerne soundsoviel bezahlen,
damit man für die Zukunft spekulieren oder nicht dekodieren sichern Preis für die Zukunft hatte Futuremark und das geht jetzt seit letztem Sonntag bei einen Sohn,
Börsen oder Finanzunternehmen der auch mit,
Bitcoins und diese größte CME heißen die Chicago wie auch immer CME die bieten das ab.
Im 18. Dezember waren denn auch Ihre Erlaubnis dafür bekommen und das WISAG geht am 8. Dezember los dass die Bitcoin Futures anbieten,
und Daten der manche gedacht dass die,
Wallstreet heilen oder der die wolfsbiss Haie dass die natürlich auf ein.
Schording setze das heißt dass sie darauf setzen dass der Bitcoin ab,
wird und und weil die darauf setzen der dann auch tatsächlich Abstürzen wird aber es ist halt jetzt letzten Sonntag zumindest nicht passiert sondern,
ganz minimal gestiegen jetzt nicht wirklich viel aber so ein bisschen Halt du wirst es nicht runter gegangen und wenn diese riesengroße Boot oder Systeme kommt am 18. dann ja ich denke mal auch nicht dass es dann abstürzt sondern das könnte dann auch er noch mal,
weiter nach oben gehen immer mit dem Zusatz dass ich keine Finanztipps gebe in Word gar keine Richtung weil.
Geht nur nach hinten los und fällt auf mich zurück habe ich kein Bock also mach das nicht.
Also lass die Finger von Bitcoins also kauf lieber Lego und vieles Monatsgehalt was ihr da investiert macht mindestens eine Woche research sage ich jetzt mal so,
und zwar Hardcore Reset nicht so ein bisschen sondern bisschen mehr.
Was man sollte nicht glauben wo man nicht weiß was das genau ist und wenn die Webseite noch so schön aussieht da gibt's auch so viel scam weil coinmarketcap sind glaube ich 1303 Dosierung gelistet,
1310 pro Woche kommt da glaube ich ein Dutzend dazu oder so jeder Idiot und sein Bruder denkt sie hat alles klar ich mach mal hier so eine kryptowährung.
Die meisten davon sind Fox von dem Ford forumford forumford,
bis man irgendwann bei Bitcoin oder ethereum oder sonst wo ankommt also z.b. auch Dash ist ja schon sehr bekannt aber Dash ist ein Fork von light-point und bleibt heute sofort von Bitcoin also und die gibt's schon ewig und davon gibt's Box und davon gibt es morgen und so weiter also,
passt auf was ihr da macht.
Das ist wirklich eine Goldgräberstimmung und die Pistolen sind alle geladen da war ein Chili Plätzchen dabei sehr lecker.
Ja was ist denn aus gibt hier so verschiedene Achsen an dem man diese ganze Debatte aufhängen muss seinerseits dieses.
Alle sind jetzt so heiß aus mitverdienen dass wir sogar was steht da jetzt mit anfängt das ist natürlich etwas was jetzt irgendwie diese ganze Krypto.
Währungs Bubble wenn sie denn eine sms noch eine ganze Weile lang,
Jobs in Altötting Spruch mit kann es Nordsee Bubble it PIN.
Für die andere Bubble für die für das Geld,
wir sind da auch ehrlich gesagt dieser ganzen Bitcoin Welt immer so ein Gefühl zu bisschen zuviel Soha,
libertäre Starter auch mit so auf der philosophisch aber Seite gesammelt,
inzwischen verschwunden glaubt die greedy people haben inzwischen übernommen.
Äußert sich etwas ersetzen.
Die libertären ja so die wie du an das Gute glauben und hier und da mit dem Bitcoin und so weiter,
die sind halt jetzt wirklich ganz ganz krass in der Minderheit und und die wie fallen fast gar nicht mehr auf also von dir hört man ja gar nicht mehr viel bei mir im room service seven wo man noch mit konkreten ist wie letzte Woche also das ist auch nur noch da kommen Leute und kaufen wie die wilden Bitcoins irgendwie und und alle spekulieren ob es noch weiter steigt und wie toll das ist aber keiner interessiert sich mehr für,
das ist halt so.
Bewährung ist dieser Staat oder wie auch immer nicht so kontrollieren kann mit Nachdrucken und so weiter und das ist halt also mit Ton ist Jan Umzäunung nämlich anonym aber.
Diese Aspekte sodass Bitcoins interessiert auch gerade irgendwie nicht so richtig viele Leute was ich finde was schon noch ein bisschen wieder mehr und Vordergrund gerückt werden sollte weil es ging so ein bisschen untersucht sein die ganzen Features die die Währung hat weil die sagen oder Bitcoin hat keine keine Deckung in Gold oder wie auch immer nur das nichts dahinter steht aber ich finde die Features von,
von kryptowährung an sich ist ja nicht nur mit Konto noch andere dass das sozusagen den den Wert ausmacht www.
Gut ist diese Währung finde wie sie praktisch für mein Anwendungsfall ist also,
Anonymität oder auch hinter den anderen wenn die Rollen nicht mehr von daher ja ich bin gleich ohnehin leider hat er geschrieben ein gutes Feature von dem Dollar wäre halt,
dass die Amis halt ihren Text in Dollar kassieren dass wir halt,
das sieht ja toll aus weil du kannst halt deinen deine Steuern dort nur mit Dollar bezahlen das ist das Feature des Donners und das stimmt so gesehen auch und aber ich finde details diese Features einer Währung sind auch wie es muss keine Deckung haben sondern es muss ja für mich.
Noch ein anderen Wert haben als nur den Wert an sich als was ich da wie ich damit arbeiten kann und das ist alles gerade so ein bisschen Hintergrund gerutscht.
Interessiert die Leute eigentlich nur wirklich wie viel wert das Bitcoin wie viel Bitcoin gerade wert ist und mehr nicht was man.
Noch damit mache gerne sehen hört sich auch gerade keine an den Gebühren da weil niemand zahlt gerade sein Burger damit nicht wirklich.
Weil wir viele scheint das schnelle Geld zu sein Laden Jade ich hoffe.
Ja kann ich jetzt noch die auch nicht sag also das dass dieser Bubble ich will jetzt nicht mehr Platz ist er nicht so toll,
ich wünsche mir wünschen das auch und die Developer machen dass er weiter sind da weiterhin schwer am Arbeiten haben jetzt hiermit,
hausgemachten sind auch immer noch dabei dass das auch Ingo endlich mal ankommt,
und arbeiten an vielen anderen Technologien wie sie das optimieren können und mehr,
privacy einführen und und was weiß ich nicht alles was sie da schicke sag mal auf diese lighting network.
Lightning network was in letzter Zeit irgendwie,
weiß ich super testundliebe Standard und dir Zeit zum ersten mal losgelegt haben da im Netz irgendwie Lightning transactions hin und her zu schieben also die sind da schon am machen aber das gerade interessiert die Leute interessiert also interessiert sich die Leute nur wie viele Bitcoin gerade wert ist und ob er dann noch steigen wird und dass du ein bisschen schade,
besser klar ich meine wir das ganze noch so volatiles und steigt,
oder wann dann nimmt man das natürlich also angenommen der Euro würde jetzt hier in seinem Wert auch die ganze Zeit so steigen und schwanken so dann würde sich das natürlich auch sofort auf die Wirtschaft auswirken und dementsprechend kommt bei Bitcoin halt keine richtige Wirtschaft.
In Wallung zumal auch muss ich sagen,
Moviestation schalt derzeit läuft der ganze Bezahlprozess halt auch schwierig ist,
allein diese Ungewissheit mit den transaktionszeiten oder Transaktionskosten.
Hier 2015 war glaube ich der bitcoin-kurs so ziemlich lange Klopp 2014 auch so,
uni 200 € saß und Zeit hast ein Jahr lang war es eigentlich gerade bei 200 € zeigt ob man die ausgemacht oder gekauft das war egal weil,
100 € hat nicht spekuliert oder gedacht ich verliere jetzt was wenn ich die jetzt schon ausgeben weil es war halt stabil so eine Weile lang,
und wenn man dachte immer treffen ist dein Burger bezahlt hat dann ist es ja so dass eben.
Selbst wenn damals die Blöcke voll gewesen wären der der Besitzer vom Roomservice helfen der sieht halt dass die Transaktion im Netzwerk gelandet ist dies war noch nicht in den Block aber er hat schon gesehen dass sie.
Dass sie im Netzwerk verteilt wird und wahrscheinlich dann irgendwann in den Block halt landet und das war dem gut genug für 14 € bei 14 € Burger,
fängt man jetzt nicht an irgendwelche großen double spend Attacken dazu fahren und deswegen war der immer happy und hat gesagt,
wenn er zum ersten Mal hier mit double spend beschissen wird und sein Burgerladen dann dann wird er anfangen sich das überlegen ob er das ändert aber das hat er bis heute nie gemacht weil,
er sieht halt dass die Transaktion ins Netzwerk gepostet wurde überall zwischengelagert wird und wahrscheinlich dann im nächsten und wenn nicht im übernächsten Block landet und das ist ihm gut genug weil diese Transaktion da wieder rauszukriegen weltweite ja überall zwischengespeicherte ist halt nicht so einfach,
also man müsste damit und ab ins Bett machen und so weiter und so fort und der hat bisher wohl die noch keiner beschnitten was ist denn die derzeitige Situation wenn man jetzt,
eine Transaktion.
Los schickt Oma sagt ich zahle keine Transaktionsgebühr für da gibt's schicke webseite die wenn man bei Google eintippen mempool und dann Leerzeichen Bitcoin.
Dann kommen da, mehrere Links und einer der hat ne richtig schön das visualisiertes heißt Jokos mempool size statistics hast du dir da ja genau das,
der macht auch bei diesem Hardware wallet tresorcode der auch mit Rum Jochen hoenicke heißt der glaube ich bin jetzt nicht so sicher doch hier genau steht der Noel Jochen hoenicke genau hier kannst du schön sehen.
Um das erste Bild ganz,
unten das blaue das ist sozusagen die Leute die 1 bis 2 Satori,
Cro bye bezahlen also eine Transaktion ist immer so sagen wir mal so um die 200 weiß groß wenn du mehr Infos hast bei mir wenn du weniger ein bisschen weniger sagen also + - 203 ist ne so und,
du musst pro.
Bald musst du Saturn zur Zeit also musst du nicht aber so wirds immer angeben die Einheit also Satori ist 10 millionste mit goldener die kleinste Einheit und die man Bitcoin gerade teilen kann.
Und ich weiß gar nicht was ein Satori gerade wer hat es ist aber ist ziemlich wenig also.
Wobei kannst du rechnen 14000 geteilt 10000000 17 $ 14000 € sagst du ja mal ein bisschen weniger von aber ist eigentlich egal.
Drücke Pausenzeit überbrücken tut er 30 Tage noch neun Jahren naja immerhin so 0,00 14.
Sind genauso etwas über 200 bei transaction größer als musstest du noch mal x 200 nehmen die Sache.
Ja was für ein 28 Cent oder sollst mal ein Satori oder wie ja okay.
Ja genau siehst du in dieser Liste das wenn du.
Einsatzort nimmt da bist du ganz ganz unten in diesem sogenannten mempool.
Rechts siehst du die größer sind jetzt ungefähr bei 120000 Transaktion die sind beim Pool drin sind und umso höher du bist in dieser Liste dort.
Umso eher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die meiner halt,
keine Transaktionen nächsten Blog aufnehmen also das ist jetzt nämlich nach der toschis probyte irgendwie sortiert.
Das heißt die gerade kommen er so Transaktion in den Block rein die.
300 bis 500 Sat Ossis haben oder auch ein bisschen drunter machen wir es nicht mehr ganz so worthless so 100 so um die 100 data sheet pro pro Byte,
die werden gerade noch abgearbeitet und kommen in den nächsten Block und sind dann sozusagen aus diesem mempool entfernt das heißt wenn du nur ein Satori pro bei bezahlst was ja fast nichts isst oder 0 halt eben dann landet.
Deine Transaktion da ganz unten und wird wahrscheinlich die nächsten paar Wochen nicht abgearbeitet werden und verfällt an irgendeiner zatvorski.
56 € ja so viel höher als vorne,
bist du das nicht verrechnet hast zwar Zeitarbeit.
X 200 Byte.
Ja wenn du das so sagst na ja also 0,001 48 ist ein bei 14000 €.
Natalia 16000000 90 100 vielleicht und etwas guten 100 Millionen.
Ja ja glaube ich aber nicht dabei weil sie halt von sehr hohen Transaktionsgebühren gelesen aber nicht gewonnen 56 € habe ich jetzt nichts,
gelesen aber wie schon kann schon schon sein ja da sind das wahrscheinlich gerade so Jungs die da halt die richtig dicken Sohn hin und herschieben.
Woran die 56 € anscheinend immer noch Peanuts sind im Gegensatz zu dem was sie sonst bezahlen oder so.
Ja gut aber das macht halt extrem schwieriger das schon klar damit kann man keinen Burger bezahlen das ist korrekt ja nicht nur kein Burger ist man da da da musst du dir schon Gedanken machen irgendwie dir was von einer wollen die anderen zuschieben die Frage ist nur.
Angenommen ich würde jetzt nur ein Satori pro bite teilen.
Die Mama nicht von null aus was gibt was zu verdienen du bist du dieser blaue blaue Balken unten ja was heißt das dass ich nie ran, genauso also bis jetzt 24 Stunden ganz oben gucken wir nur Widerrufsfrist.
Hoch hoch hoch,
war ganz oben asmissen runtergescrollt gerade genau da schalt mal auf eine Woche oder zwei Wochen sogar damit wir mal so bisschen Überblick haben was so in der letzten Zeit passiert ist siehst du also wir sind jetzt relativ hoch weil es der 7. Dezember ist es abgegangen,
aber vorher kannst du sehen da wurden auch schon also es wurden auch schon mal billigere abgearbeitet mit.
Zum Bereich von 500 also also wenn das jetzt auf jeden Fall diese Webseite yahoo.de aufrufen dort wo halt das sehr gut visualisiert das wie viel.
Wievielter toschis gerade sind Überweisung kostet und wie hoch die Chancen sind,
dass man sein überall Suzanne transaction durch kriegt und wie viel Saturn,
sobald man einstellen sollte das kann man da wirklich sehr gut grafisch erkennen,
also man sieht hier alles was da in dem Graphen drin ist ist nicht reingekommen dass das was ich sehe oder,
Lösung der Cash an Transaktionen der der wartet abgearbeitet zu werden das nennt man mempool das hat jeder Bitcoin Demon der läuft hat diesen mempool,
und jeder meiner wird dann hat er diesen Tempel auch und immer der Meile holt sich natürlich die die Rosine raus also die wo er am meisten Satori,
cobaltum wie kassiert weil er hat ja nur dieses eine Megabyte plus jetzt so ein bisschen extra mit dem Sekt mit und so weiter behandelt eine gewisse.
Menge Anbeißen der will natürlich soviel Sartorius pro bald wie möglich verdienen also nimmt er natürlich von,
oben die Transaktion die die meisten Sartorius probyte halt bezahlen und arbeitet das ab und dann gerade sehr viele Blöcke untereinander kommen dann arbeitet sich das natürlich runter weil da sind die schicken Rosinen alle weg und dann gibt es,
du solltest Andy die kleineren ProSieben oder wie immer man das nennt die billigeren Transaktion aber das wird halt unwahrscheinlich dass er runter kommt bis bis eine Transa Toshi providers,
hast ja siehst ja das war schon lange nicht mehr der Verein Satori pro beides einfach nicht nicht.
Genug auch in den guten Zeiten hat das nicht wirklich geklappt das bedeutet aber dass eigentlich das Transaktionsvolumen der Zeit auch krass hoch ist auf jeden Fall.
Na das ist der halt gerade so alle kaufen gerade wie blöd und dann du hast natürlich ab dann ist sozusagen der Laden voll,
aber wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt alle 10 Minuten dann Block habe und ihren Blog passen eine bestimmte Anzahl von Transaktionen rein dann ist ja die Gesamtanzahl der Transaktion im Prinzip konstant.
Nee.
Erstens eine Transaktion kommt drauf an was sie für Inputs und Outputs hat und die Hand und kann verschieden großer du kannst auch eine 10 Kilobyte Überweisung machen wenn du 1000 Inputs hast und du zahlst an Pausen und Autos das kann man machen in einer Transaktion,
aber du hast ganz viele Einzelteile und du willst,
online überweisen und du musst sozusagen mehrere coin zusammen nehmen damit du diese Summe dir leisten kannst dass du mehrere Inputs und ein Auto das ist auch größer als 200 weiter sodass klassisches 2 inputs 2 Auto zu ungefähr dass es so ungefähr 200 bei Neckermann Mittel,
im Mittelmeer in Mittelhessen falls das Bitcoin Netzwerk gerade überfordert mit,
der Anzahl der Transaktionen der Laden ist voll und manche müssen vor der Tür warten nach sollte das heißen die Transaktionsgebühren soweit hochgehen heißt halt einfach nur dass die Leute die unbedingt.
Herobrine wollen überbieten Aldi im Essener zocken.
Darüber erhöhen einfach das Angebot und und das wie so ein Auktion auf freie Plätze für den Bitcoin Flieger,
wer bin ich genug bezahlt kommt nicht rein und muss draußen stehen bleiben. SV bin auch die Möglichkeit.
Dann sag mir wo das Netz den Stinkefinger ansagt geht nicht durch so was mein dann kann ich das kann schön.
Nee weil die Transaktion ist ja im Netz und die ist verteilt sich auf alle Not weltweit und warte dort irgend so ein Blatt bekommen das kannst du nicht kämpfen,
also müssen kannst du dich auch nicht drauf lassen könntest mir seinen Eltern ist das der Scheiß gemacht mach mal die Transaktion mich damals die bei mir weg wenn ich das jetzt die Toilette sauber um sie zu löschen aber du findest ja alle hunderttausend andere Leute nicht wo die bei denen Bitcoin not drin ist und kannst die da nicht löschen so das geht nicht,
aber die Bitcoin Jungs haben sich irgendwann mal.
Breitschlagen lassen ein Feature das Implementieren was RBF heißt das heißt replace by fee das heißt du kannst eine Transaktion ersetzen durch eine andere.
Indem du die Gebühr erhöht hast du machst einfach deine gleiche Transaktion noch mal höchst aber die Gebühr und dadurch wird die alte ersetzt.
Das ist aber oft schnell das heißt deine alte Transaktion muss schon auf den Fleck drin haben dass das mit der Erlaubnis damit nämlich der Händler sehen kann wenn wir uns denn treffen dann Burger bezahlst und der sieht ey du hast dir dieses Flag gesetzt dass du diese.
Diese Gebühr ändern könntest aber man kann ich nur die Gebühren an Sonne auch das Ziel wo die Transaktion hingetan das heißt aber könnte man prima so ein double spend machen du zeichnen Burger die ist raus aus dem Laden sagst mir nicht er würde Gebühren zahle jetzt aber wieder auf mein eigenes Konto,
also das würde der dann anrufst ja nichts davon sehen dass du dieses Flag benutzt und dass du das machen kannst und dann wird das wahrscheinlich sagen nee dann warten wir schon mal hier bis das im Block ist und du das nicht mehr ersetzen kannst,
aber Behinderung Stansfield seven übernachten ja.
Adresse dass ich mich zur Not oder wie auch immer die das dann da aus anhörst muss man natürlich je nachdem machen.
Na dann aber schon mal heute eine Weile gewartet weil die Transaktion nicht durchkommen das glaube ich auch schon mal so ein bisschen an hat ein bisschen gedauert.
Sorry das kannst du machen jedenfalls wenn ein Fehler passiert du hast die Gebühr zu wenig gemacht und du hast dieses replace by fee Flag gesetzt dann der höchste einfach die Gebühr oder wenn du genauso wenn und Fehler gemacht hast mit der Zieladresse die war nicht richtig dann kannst du das,
auch dann ändern und mit einer höheren Gebühr sozusagen die,
alte Transaktionen überschreiben bei der meiner sieht natürlich dann beide.
Meldegebühr danach von der zweiten Transaktion nicht erhöht dann nimmt er meiner natürlich trotzdem I auch wenn du gesagt hast du jetzt jetzt gerne die II Durchwahl der meiner dem ist das egal der sortiert nach nach der toschis provide ne.
Deswegen muss man halt die Gebühr schon immer hören also nachträglich niedriger machen geht nicht das interessiert in meiner nicht das so beantwortet okay.
Merkel sagt man das heißt man muss eigentlich wenn man ein gewisses Interesse daran hat das.
Die Transaktion überhaupt innerhalb eines nennenswerten Zeitraums durchgeht schon eine ganze Menge Geld,
weil zurzeit schon bei der Heimwerker so hoch ist und da ist ziemlich voll mein Tipp ist wenn einer das also,
lines Transaktion sollte man gerade schon irgendwie auch vermeiden weil das Gebühren mäßig lohnt sich einfach nicht wenn man doch irgendwie was durch kriegen musste man willst einigermaßen billig haben am Wochenende baut sich dieser mempool immer so ein bisschen ab also man kann schon sehen in der Woche,
baut sich der mempool auf das ist aber besonders voll und am Wochenende baut er sich ab da ist weniger los und dadurch sinkt natürlich am Wochenende auch die Gebühren und man kriegt seine,
Transaktion so er durch das noch mal sehen wenn man dir so ein bisschen raussuchen kannst du beim letzten Wochenende gucken da war immer so ist da so eine senckenberg,
und dann siehst du da wird ein bisschen bisschen billiger an die Daytrader dann Wochenende.
Wir haben die Banken wahrscheinlich nicht oder was auch immer da passiert die Extended da können die keine Euros auf die Action geladen und wenn sie keine Euros haben können dann keine Bitcoins kaufen und keinen keine Deals machen und dann sind weniger Transaktion da,
oder soll ich habe keine Ahnung also das muss ja irgendwie so damit zu tun haben das Schlagen an dem die kleinen vor.
Als wie das wird automatisch berechnet und das ist aber auch alles so von ganz früher wo die das nur.
Nach der Größe des Blogs und wie berechnet haben oder so aber gar nicht nach nach was jetzt genau die Gebühren sind die die durch ging und wie viel wie viel Grad office pro beide bezahlt haben also die die Algorithmen die das automatisch berechnet haben die gab's waren aber noch nicht so gut werden in letzter Zeit aber gerade weil kein Problem ist,
Zoetermeer mehr aufmerksam,
heute aufgegeben und die verbessern sich gerade aber glaub das bestes noch wenn man da so ein bisschen bei dieser Seite z.b. selber guckt und das so custom mäßig so ein bisschen einstellen muss aber auch,
ja bisschen glaube ich ein Gefühl dafür entwickeln Wasser durch geht und was nicht ist ein bisschen wie,
so Google es nervt ein bisschen darauf hinaus dass man so in in Echtzeit den Bestpreis,
bieten muss oder sozusagen eine bewerbungs Platzierung zu kaufen.
Nur dass das hier so ein bisschen anders rum läuft.
So muss Angebot machen und dann hoffen dass es irgendwie dadurch geht irgendwann mal hinhaut so wäre das ja bei den Google-Apps also ja okay jetzt,
geht's jetzt jetzt bitte ich euch einen Platz bietet malo dann weißt du auch sofort dass du nicht drangenommen wurdest wird er ja auch so.
Mit den mit den Gebühren bei der transaction wenn du es halt sofort im nächsten Block durch haben willst dann musst halt wirklich viele Sattel bezahlen damit du wirklich an der Spitze des Eisberges bis damit der meiner sozusagen bei der nimmt der immer die obersten Weg wird sein damit auf jeden Fall dabei bist.
Wenn du dir aber leisten kannst weil er z.b. von deiner eigenen wallet.
Zu deiner Hardware wallet überträgt das und dir ist egal ob das auch mal zwei Wochen dauert dann kannst du natürlich ein deutlich weniger Sat1 Pro bei Tim und irgendwann wird dir dann schon mal mit durchrutschen.
Und wenn nicht dann machst du es halt irgendwann in der Zukunft noch mal deswegen da kann man schon sprachliches verrechnet vorhin war doch um 10 Uhr den falsch.
Ja ich habe doch eine Null ja warte mal.
Bitte noch mal wäre es dann nicht im Interesse von so großen Hintern weh jetzt bitstamp oder coinbase wenn ihre eigenen mining Pools noch betreiben die sozusagen seinen transaktionspreis,
drücken geht der nicht ne aber zumindestens übersenden Sie auch selbst wieder noch weniger also die meiner verdienen an den Transaktionen Bitcoin weil sie hat selber meint.
Ja verdienen Sie auch selber den Transaktionen ist das sowieso irgendwie eigentlich dann am Ende auch egal,
na ja im Prinzip wer ist der Führer Kundennutzen besser wenn Sie den transaktionspreis drücken könnten sozusagen.
Ja aber wie wollen wir das machen,
indem sie halt Böhmermann aber dennoch dem Gewinn ja nicht haben das heißt sie müssten das gerne Technik benutzen wie halt die Transaktionsgebühren sinken ohne dass sie halt irgendein Nachteil haben ja oder sie nehmen halt nur eigene Transaktionen entblock.
Die wissen halt welche Transaktionen über die Plattform gehen und nehmen nur die in den Block.
Weiß nicht ob man das so dann könnte sie aber welche finden was aber auf jeden Fall geht es gibt ja diese dieses neue segregated witness dort werden auch die Transaktion theoretisch minimal kleiner und es passen auch.
Also erstens wenn die Transaktion leicht kleiner zweitens passen mehr in den Block rein was ja auch wichtig wie viel Halt abgearbeitet werden können damit der mempool halt nicht voll ist dann singt der Preis ja auch,
und wenn Sie diese neue Technik einfach mal aufnehmen würden und das haben ganz viele exchanges machen noch keine segregated witness Transaktion und,
das müssten wir eigentlich mal mehr machen damit Teil da auch die Preise sinken und der mempool sich schnell abbaut aber coinbase grau glaube ich hat gerade vor 23 Tagen angekündigt dass sie demnächst das mit dem Sex mit mal machen werden und,
viele andere vielleicht auch und dann müsste dass ich ein bisschen entspannen aber ich denke gerade dass der halt so stark alleine das wird,
vielleicht ist es ja so ein bisschen verbessern aber auch nicht so machen das in nächster Zeit so einen mempool auch wieder komplett leer weil wenn es perfekt läuft dann ist der Leander dann ist da wenn der Block abgearbeitet ist ist dann so dann der mempool theoretisch auf Null weil dann,
alles was das in ein Block passte und,
habe gearbeitet das war früher der Fall das glaube ich ist jetzt in der nächsten Zeit erstmal nicht mehr so die.
L200 weiß also wovon geht was.
Wie viel Byte brauche ich denn für eine Transaktion also wohnen will wie rechnet man das zusammen dürfen,
drauf an Mann wenn du ich rechnet man mit geraden Zahlen auch wenn das jetzt irrsinnig hohe Werte sind aber es geht halt besser wenn du jetzt an mich nach fünf Bitcoins bezahlen musst und dein Köln den du irgendwann mal früher bei Mount gox aber mal gekauft das ist der 6 mit ganz groß dann hast du einen Input von.
Sec Bitcoin davon gehen fünf also dann an mich als Output,
einer bleibt übrig das ist sozusagen das Wechselgeld an Dich weil davon kriegt wahrscheinlich 0,995 oder so und diese Rest 0,005 ist so die transaction Gebühr,
die Differenz ist immer das was der meiner bekommt so und das ist dann sozialinfo deine 61 Autos meine fünf und ein Auto Teil 1 und das war sozusagen.
Und dass er bestimmt die Größe dieser Transaktion weil das ja mal mit den Signaturen ist wo es hingeht und wo es herkommt,
und das ist schon relativ kleinen noch besser wäre wenn du natürlich ein Input.
Ein Auto Test weil besser geht's nicht also kleiner gefährlich und das werde ich eine Transaktion die geht also ich eine coin an eine andere Person,
genau verkaufe ohne das Wechselgeld aber da fällt meistens macht man so eine Dinger wenn man an sich selber bezahlt dann willst du sozusagen eine Summe die Duschen hast an irgendwie eine andere Adresse von dir schieben warum auch immer Hardware wallet oder wie auch immer und hast du einen Input 1 output,
mit einer leichten Differenz weil der meiner will auch ein bisschen was haben und dann schiebst du einen rein und 0,99 Bitcoin wieder raus oder das ist sozusagen die billigste Transaktion dies dies gibt und die kostet dann so 150 bei so oder so vielleicht oder,
180 keine Ahnung aber man kann doch hier so multi6 Zeug machen dass du sozusagen,
zwei Keys brauchst damit man das auch wieder ausgeben kann und zweitens müssen ja dann gelistet werden und Schmuck dann bist du bei einer,
Transaktion die dann locker mal irgendwie ein Kilobyte groß ist und die kostet dann natürlich auch dementsprechend und das lohnt sich natürlich nicht mehr nur deine Burger da bezahlt muss ich aber schon wenn du irgendwie deine 10bit kommt gerade durch die Gegend schiebst.
Oder welche anderen Konstruktor was ist ja noch gibt es das man ja auch so Überweisung so über die Zeit locken kann das die anderen bestimmten Block Nummer irgendwie du kannst die ersten 1000 Blöcken oder irgendwie so wieder ausgeben vorher nicht und so wenn er nur so special Script dass die ein bisschen größer sind,
und muss in der Zukunft noch mehr von geben wird ein bisschen ist serienmäßig dann wär natürlich auch die Transaktionen größer erforschen die aber auch gerade wie man da 200.
Beide ungefähr ungefähr wenn man hier bei blockchain Info guck kann man sich dadurch sympa Transaktion durchgehend alter ich jetzt hier mal geguckt,
somit Poster T6 also wenn man jetzt gerade mal nicht sicher was durch haben will ja sicher.
Dann bedeutet das 300 Satori pro weit.
Ja zu dem Zeitpunkt agraria ja ich habe jetzt hier die letzten acht stunden angeklickt und niemand hat mehr als 300 zahlen müssen um was durch zu kriegen.
So will ich das jetzt mal Deutener wenn du nur zwei oder was ist das hier ist das 300 und das hat,
das ist mehr also wundern Sie ganz links ist doch die Liste da kannst du doch die Farbe gucken guck mal da ist doch das Orange is 300 und 500.
Also bis 500 ah okay gut also dann einfach mal weiter.
Ja sag mal was 200 und 200 wäre jetzt gerade auch noch so durchgegangen rechne mal mal das so und ich gehe jetzt mal von dem.
Bitcoin Preis von.
14000 15000 € aus um 14:15 Uhr machen aber eigentlich zu hoch.
Na gut Waldwegen 914 sind 0 mal hören.
A14 26 Grad der groß also sind 0,0001 4 Cent.
Dafür ein weit ne das muss ja mal 200 Meilen weit richtig genau sind 200 x 200.
Sind 0,028.
Dass ich wieder verrechnet werden Wolfram Alpha.
Ich kopiere hier irgendwie die Zahl eine Eins mit.
Na ob ihr das aus der Wikipedia-Seite über Sat Toshiba sie haben noch.
Wie was haben wir haben 200 bei smile 200 OC,
das sind 40000.
Satoshi 100000000 ne einsatztasche ist 100 Millionen himmelhorn gesagt.
Habe ich gesagt aber war doch 100 ml habe ich 10 vertan also es sei denn irgendjemand hat gerade die Wikipedia-Seite ganz brutal vor meinen Augen verändert.
14000 € / die 100 Millionen 0,0001 4 pro Saturn.
Ich komme auch 2 $ 5,50 € x 200.
Meine weilhartner also x 200 x 200 sind 5,60 € ja ganz schön teuer für Burger 5,60 € und eine beliebige.
Einfache Überweisung Jeddeloh am Wochenende,
oder komm heute vielleicht das Schlechte daran ist das wenn du dann dein Burger mit 3 € bezahlen willst du trotzdem mir diese 5 € Gebühr bezahlt,
wenn du eine günstige Transaktion ach die kann ja teurer sein wenn du mehrere Inputs hast weil deine Coins sind gerade testblätter tja so aber so dann Zeit zu 5 € das schön ist aber auch,
für die die Banker Freund sind natürlich weil selbst wenn du da jetzt 10000000 an einem Stück hin und her schieben es gibt halt diesen prozentualen Anteil nicht weil du kannst die 10 Millionen höchstwahrscheinlich auch mit.
Ja nun die Million wäre nett wahrscheinlich als einzelne koexistieren aber bestimmt auch locker mit einem halben Kilobyte oder ein Kilobyte und wie durch die Gegend schieben das heißt der Banker schiebt seine Millionen dafür 10 20 € durch die Gegend das hast du wahrscheinlich sonst nicht so.
Also bei Paypal wärst du dann irgendwie oder was heißt das wahrscheinlich auch die allermeisten Transaktion die da gerade laufen ja so um im großen Stil sind.
Wäre ich mir nicht so sicher ja alles so ab 100 € ist ja dann schon.
Trotzdem verdient sich da irgendjemand gerade dumm und dusselig na ich wollte letztens was bezahlen mit mit.
Bitcoins und wollte das Konto da sehen mit bei dem Händler wie ich das bezahlen kann war ein bisschen was Größeres und haben sie mir auch mit PayPal angeboten und mein weil ich das noch mal mit Paypal zahle kostet mich das 80 € extra.
Dachte du musst jetzt nicht so sein habe dann auch direkt überweisen geklickt habe dann geguckt was mich das dann im Beton kostet und ich glaube ich,
12,50 € dann bezahlt bitcoin.de die transaction fee.
Und dann war das durch ja gut dass du zu Paypal dass ich habe gesagt da sind die Alternativen durchaus vorhanden ja auch jetzt wieder ein bisschen was Größeres deswegen waren die 12,50 € jetzt auch mehr oder weniger war mir schnuppe aber bei kleineren Sachen geht das natürlich nicht ich sehe dass ein,
was heißt denn das Wasser Wasser nein also wenn wir jetzt noch mal von diesen was hat mir vorhin 200 wissen von 200 Santoshi probyte ausgegangen.
So 220 probyte und wie viel Byte sind da drin ein Megabyte.
Problock mein Fotoblog na jetzt mit dem segregated witness ein bisschen mehr aber dazu müsste man auch Segel Geld wird es benutzen aber so lange bevor seltenes kam das war ein Megabyte.
Okay also Megabyte in Millionen 100 Millionen sind unser Toshi also sozusagen.
Durch also sozusagen die meiner gerade an 100/100 Bitcoin pro Block den man so sagen an Gebühren einnehmen kann,
nee deutlich mehr da könnt jetzt mal auf die Webseite gehen blockchain.com also nicht blockchain sondern dass er so ein bisschen ab,
abgekratzt dann kommt der blockchain raus dass er geht nicht ganz rum das n nehme Block schaer.com.
Und dort glaube ich weil das jetzt für Bitcoin und Bitcoin cash ist muss jetzt mal hier.
Explorer 4000er genau klicken so und da kannst du auch wenn du ein bisschen seitwärts Kreuz oder die einfach Fullscreen macht das Ding dann siehst du auch die die Gebühren pro Block die da eingenommen werden.
Oder Musterseite sonst nützt er mach mal,
wie mein puls Alter breiter gebrauchen dann bereit oder so.
Hallo also für die Hörer wir gehen das auf die Seite blockchain.com.
Von dort wohin und dort der der erste große Button Explorer vorhanden nineteen 1000 Blocks den müsste mal klicken so da kann man jetzt sehen hier die Blöcke.
Und ich schieß hier da siehst du die fies diese gerade einnehmen ist 1,2 Bitcoin 1,6 mit Konan ist doch ein Block mit 3,7 Bitcoin 3,9 Bitcoin also das ist teilweise nehmen Sie ein Viertel,
von dem was generiert wird nehmen Sie schon als Gebühren eines gab auch schon im historischen ersten Moment war vor ein paar Wochen da war ein Block hat mehrgebühren gehabt.
Als er generiert hat also degenerieren da gerade problock 12.9 Bitcoins ne das wird halbiert sich alle vier Jahre der mit 50 angefangen dann 25er sind vorbei 12 und Halbzeit irgendwie anderthalb Jahren oder so,
und dabei haben sie mehr Gebühren eingenommen als diese 12 x Bitcoin und so das ist ja soljan der Zukunft auch so sein also irgendwann.
Singt es ja demnächst auf 6,25.
Bekommt diese generieren unter bis dahin werden die die Gebühren wahrscheinlich schon deutlich dadrüber liegen das heißt das 12 wechselt sich um Bitcoin anziehst.
Bloß noch mal die 12 ne also quasi so 25/25 Bitcoin.
24/25 Bitcoin für 10 Minuten Rechnung Rechenleistung oder,
ja mehr Rechenleistung wie lange insgesamt schon weltweit aber der Typ der das bekommen hat hat wahrscheinlich länger dadran gerechnet weil er findet ja nicht alle 10 Minuten ein Block mit seinem meiner ja aber so grundsätzlich.
Insgesamt weltweit kann man das so sagen ca alle 10 Minuten.
Komm da irgendwie jetzt zurzeit so 16 17 Uhr Bitcoins raus im Durchschnitt 4 Minuten,
minus eine Stromkosten natürlich da haben wir ja wieder das Problem hat der Tim auch auf seine mit dem A10 sag mal 15 Bitcoin 14000 €.
Alle 10 Minuten 210000 €.
Sind aber immer nur die gleichen Puls dieses meinen ne ja gibt es nicht mehr viele. Ich glaube es gibt noch Wunder so.
Also Dutten sage ich mal wovon aber wenn es nutzen um das voll zu kriegen sind auch schon ganz viele kleine bei dem man so die Hardcore Pool für so eine Handvoll.
Ich glaube wenn man da kann man bestimmt irgendwie das ganz cool dieser dieser Laden ja,
Blog ja da kannst du bestimmt auch irgendwo klicken und dann kommt das neue Grafikkarten Grafik mit mit so einer Tortengrafik wie die die Blogs verteilt sind in den in den Puls aber,
dr müsstest du mal eine Seite zurück gehen wieder in dieser Übersicht du meinst wie die geheimen auf die Haut auf die Hauptseite einmal backpack.
Genau da musst du mal gucken ob es da irgendwie was gibt wo wo die Puls um die gelistet sind also weiter unten an diesen ganzen Links irgendwo da.
Das Ende der das Kreuz hier so durch auf der linken Seite scrollt der durch und wenn er in der Mitte ist,
genau da klick mal drauf kommen da drauf klicken ne distribution oder was.
Ja wenn die geilsten aber kannst schon so lang fulldizi.com bitte Sie. Ob.
Viabtc slushpool f2pool das sind so die ganz groß und dann gibt es noch mal so eine Handvoll kleiner und dann war es das also,
ja wir können Business oder mining business is Hardcore heutzutage ne also das sind hier.
Die Firma Zeitgeist aber es gibt eine Bude heißt bitmain die machen ja auf ihren eigenen ASIC Chip.
Weiten sich sozusagen selber mit dem eigenen Chip ich glaub,
behaupten Bomben haben ist halt weil sie noch selber nutzen das mit dem verkaufen das machen die glaube ich nur so zu ja.
So etwas aufhört lass es mal noch zu einem letzten wichtigen Punkt kommen.
Ohne machen gesprochen haben muss werden wir alle sterben.
Den Bitcoin nee weil das so viel Strom verbraucht.
Das schwierig die Sonne platzt weil sie so lange wird von den mining Boards glaube ich glaube ich nicht.
Irgendjemand wie das in der Zukunft weitergeht weiß ich auch nicht so genau so unendlich kann das so nicht weitergehen das ist mir schon auch irgendwie klar was da die Lösung ist habe ich aber keine Ahnung und ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht dass da irgendwie sie groß irgendwas,
Landau umzustellen Heizung wie viel Strom,
bis zu einem Kontinent schon um wie alles gelesen und ich möchte das nicht ganz easy durchrechnen.
Diese Batman bitmain Bude diesen ASIC Chip da macht die haben den ja auch bei sich auf der Webseite und die geben mir auch exakt an wie viel,
weil das ist das was man heutzutage wissen will wie viel Strom der für wie viel Hecht pro Sekunde verbraucht also Sonnen ratio und ich glaube das war irgendwie der der hat.
Terahash verbraucht ihren asicminer oder nee also Fleisch pro Sekunde macht er und der verbraucht dabei ca 1,2 Kilowatt also könnte man sagen 1,4.
Kilowatt und wenn man das so umrechnet dann mit der der Herr Schrade die dieses Bitcoin Netzwerk insgesamt gerade sie hat glaube ich kam daraus dass es ca in Gigawatt ist.
Golkonda ja nee nicht pro Sekunde.
Ein Gigawatt Dauerlast genau dauert ein Gigabyte also ein Kraftwerk ja 10.
Fukushima Blog hatte glaube ich 600 Megawatt sind also knapp knapp zwei Fukushima Blöcke.
Also ich habe ja mal so einen total schön geschriebenen Artikel gelesen dass z.b. China,
die meine einfach nur den überflüssigen Strom von dem Staudamm verbrennen der sonst irgendwie ganz mühsam irgendwie abgearbeitet mir hat das habe ich auch mal erzählt aber auch immer mit der nebenbei bemerkt und dass das auch nur so Hörensagen sicher dass du da glaubt,
keine,
belegbaren Quellen bei so richtig aber China muss man da ist ja schon auch wirklich ziemlich groß das Land ne also von Russland jetzt mal abgesehen ist das ja schon ganz schöne Hoschi und das kann schon stimmen dass die da,
im Land verteilt halt viele Wasserkraftwerke haben wo sie das eben nicht bis nach Shanghai über über 1000 km da Leitung legen können und also die könnte plausibel seine Geschichte,
weiß ich aber nicht aber der meiner bezahlt hat mehr Strom als der Bauer deswegen darf er wieder sende eine Petroleumlampe anmachen nee das war wohl anders da gabs,
gabs irgendwie so ein Bericht dass die Chinesen den diesen Minikraftwerk Betreibern da verboten haben,
dass sie den Mailand irgendwie special deals machen wir ja eigentlich alle den gleichen Strompreis bezahlen da und der Main hat dann gesagt er hier ich nehme deinen Strom ab mach mir guten Preis und alles ist in Tüten wo der auf der sozialen Überlast ist die abgefangen werden muss seine Tage auch schon Geld dafür.
Haare haben wir jetzt von oben so eine Anweisung gekriegt dass du das nicht so machen soll die sollen der Preis für alle gleich bleiben keine special deals für meiner dieses.
Also das könnt ihr auch schon wieder so ein Hinweis dafür sein dass es wirklich stimmt dass die die wasserkraftwerksbetreiber da den billig den Strom an die meiner verkaufen.
Aber hier gibt's übrigens auch so ein Ding in der Übersicht von empty blocks.
Und das sind tatsächlich gestern war einer vorgestern ja es ist immer das gibt ein Pool assistant wo das mache ich schon seit Jahren so,
nee sind ganz unterschiedlich Boya müsste aber meistens and Pool sein oder Wer ist Zweiter bei aber ist nicht herausragend keine Ahnung was da immer so Hemd.
Keine Transaktionen Audi sie machen leeren Block da kommen nur die zwölf der Bitcoins raus die haben keine Gebühren weil sie keine Transaktion mit drin haben das einfach leer und ein Grund war.
Dabei also früher war das immer n cool wenn gerade im Blog gefunden wurde.
Dann musst du ja auf der Welt und dann verteilt werden wenn der bei enpuls schon ankommt.
Der müsste den jetzt erst durchchecken die ganzen Transaktion die da drin sind bevor er sagt das stimmt alles und dann auf Basis von dem den durchrechnen zu können,
und weil die diese Zeit irgendwie sich einspannen wollen diese paar Sekunden diese dafür brauchen liegen die schon mal einfach so mit einem leeren Block los,
bevor sitzen in ihren Blog Transaktion reinmachen die in dem anderen schon drin Wannweil das müssten Sie das checken weil sie müssen erst ihre mempool sitzen von dem befreien was in den Blog von der Vorsitzenden abgearbeitet wurde und deswegen rechnen die schon mal so auf Verdacht sozusagen.
Mit einem leeren Block los damit Sie diesen Zeitvorsprung haben und wenn sie aber dann so zeige diesen 34 Sekunden.
Muss ich das machen zufällig dann auch noch ein Blog finden dann ist der Block halt leer und dann ist den das halt egal was ich warte immer noch schneller als der Rest.
Was sonst müssten sie 23 Sekunden lang rechnen bevor sie dann auf Basis,
das letzten Block sozusagen den nächsten Anfrage füllen können um mit dem zu arbeiten also sieht so aus als wenn das inzwischen alle so machen.
Könnte sein Verein genieße cool was sollte man eigentlich was in das Bett.
Netzwerk einbauen das wenn ich als als Note irgendwie bin der Sohn lehrerblog vorbeikommt ja und mein mempool ist aber voll das heißt da hätten voll viele Transaktionen drin dann können wir es gibt Milch und es gibt eigentlich immer welche dass man dann sag doch geht in den der ist zwar da der Block aber,
zumindest mal so frech und reicht den nicht weiter durch und darf ich könnte dein anderer der vielleicht voll ist dann eher Chancen haben damit man den so bisschen zu mir sagt er ich ich.
Mach euren Blog langsamer macht das man nicht ich kann dass man nicht verhindern weil technisch ist das alles korrekt aber ich kann ihn ja zumindest ausbremsen wenn sich da drauf alle einigen würden das ist auch sehr sehr Unfall und freundlich.
Ich meine hat Maja auch im Netzwerk auch voll scheiße ja jetzt schon irgendwie so viel gerechnet am Ende.
War das mit Obi eine Person 12 Lehrerin verdienen kann ja aber das Drehen ist natürlich auch noch immer mehr um bei wieder gesehen dass die Transaktionsgebühren sind ja auch inzwischen so hoch.
Das ist eigentlich das man sich nicht mehr so richtig erlauben kann dass man leeren Block macht weil dann gehen ja die inzwischen 234 Bitcoin,
Gebühren gehen der Flöten und das wird dann in zweieinhalb Jahren wenn sich das auf 6 irgendwie verringert und die Gebühren wahrscheinlich noch viel höher sind dann kannst du dir das nicht mehr erlauben das zu tun das heißt das f***** du schon alleine das Problem,
der Markt regelt das nur noch eine Frage sie gibt es gibt es eine Metrik blogs with most coin days destroyed.
Okay kann ich dir auch erklären habe ich mich auch früher mal 100 und zwar könnte man ja sagen.
Also man will wissen wie viel Bitcoin volume sozusagen pro Tag ja durch die Gegend geschoben wird damit man weiß viactiv der Markt gerade ist oder eine Währung z.b. die sage mal hier activity für bestimmte kryptowährung ist hier.
Fünf Millionen Dollar Rechner schon mal auf damit man alle miteinander vergleichen kann die Währung ja 5 Millionen Dollar durch die Gegend hier schieb 20 Millionen Dollar durch die ging dann kann man das zu vergleichen viactiv so eine währungs Optima benutzt wird z.b. jetzt aber das Problem bei Bitcoin ich könnte ja.
Sag mir mal hier meine 1000000 bit konnte ich ja Besitzer ne könnte ich eigentlich jeden Tag die ganze Zeit im Kreis durch die Gegend schieben.
Weißt du ich schick dir auf eine neue Adresse wenn es durch ist dann eine Stunde später dann schiebe ich die wieder auf den Adresse von mir und da wird es heißen jedesmal geht dann wären eine Milliarde eine Milliarde Dollar durch die Gegend rum und das mehrmals am Tag activity ist also ziemlich hoch und damit man das nicht so hin schummeln kann,
Mann wie heißt das coin coin days destroyed das oder was war das heißt,
die nehmen das Alter deiner Keuschheit wenn ich jetzt Coins habe von vorletztem Jahr also ich habe einen Bitcoin der genau bin ich genau vor einem Jahr bekommen habe dann habe ich genau 365 coinbase destroyed wenn es den eine Stunde später aber noch mal schiebe.
Dann habe ich eigentlich nur 0, weißt schon,
destroyed weil der ja voll frisch halten ich habe den ja gerade erst bewegt das gar nicht viel passiert und das ist dieses coinbase destroyed damit man weiß,
das künstlich nicht erhöhen kann indem man da Sachen im Kreis,
da kannst du so sehen aber was verhindert denn dann das Alter dieser coin also.
Na gar nichts man kann nur besser bemessen ob da wirklich Aktivität ist oder nicht also es kann keiner schummeln dir mal seine Coins da im Kreis dreht,
und früher war das Alter der Coins auch noch wichtig.
Inzwischen glaube ich ist das aber nicht mehr so da wurde nämlich der Preis also die Gebührenberechnung anstatt je nachdem wie alt deine Coins wann umso billiger war die transaction Gebühr.
Also das war früher immer so als die Blöcke noch nicht voll war da wurde das einfach mal so berechnet wie viel wie viel die Gebühr sein soll und umso älter deine neuen Warum so billiger war die Gebühr um so eine Art Edos Features haben als jemand der alte Coins hat.
Der kann die halt billig bewegen,
aber der attack hat ja sozusagen die Coins die ganze Zeit im Kreis drehen lässt um halt den Block einfach voll zu machen ohne dass da wirklich was passiert der muss Teil 4 bezahlen weil die so Frischwaren,
das war so ja eigentlich hässlich aber eigentlich gar nicht richtig in Forsten Weilheim in der nur die Transaktion viel Laktase.
Ja aber der müsste die dann halt erhöhen wenn er seine frischen Coins immer so ein Quatsch dass die Attacke wird dadurch teurer sowohl das wollten die dadurch erreichen er wurde aber wer soll das in Forsten also ich meine das machte weil wenn ich jetzt der bin aber nicht liont.
Kann ich gleich aus der Premier Inn das ist nicht da drin ist.
Und ich weiß nicht wie das erforscht wurde früher als ich glaube früher war eigentlich alles ein bisschen egal weil die Blöcke waren leer und neu,
also die die transaction die muss ja nicht nur,
also du schiebst sie am Netzwerk raus aber du schiebst ja nicht direkt in meiner sondern der Skipiste soziales Netzwerk und die springt der von Note zu Note bis sie bei den meiner irgendwie ankommt da sind dieses Jahr riesengroßen Mesh network könnte man sagen sondern die notes.
Mittendrin wenn die sagen ja nicht hier die Gebühr stimmt nicht und die wegwerfen oder nicht WLAN könnte man sagen dann kommt ihr halt nie bei meiner an oder zu müssen die so schnell und,
ja irgendwie so viel aber das ist so so war das früher das ist alles nicht mehr so,
guten alten Tage ja guten an Bitcoin Tage das war so vor zwei Jahren noch oder so dann war es irgendwann voll.
Dhalucard Orkantief ich glaube heute schon erstmal,
doch sonst noch irgendwas nee also das nächste spannende eigenes ist halt der 18.12 dieses cm future Trading da los geht das ist diese riesengroße,
größter Trading oder future market Bude die es gibt auf der Welt Chicago irgendwas,
der Preis noch mal auch wahrscheinlich aber habe da nicht bei mir gehört ich sage mal lass die Finger davon alles danger danger.
Das hat nicht euer Haus und eure Pension und so weiter die Ersparnisse eurer Kinder,
sondern.
Geht weil sie arbeiten genau oder so.
Schreib mal gucken wie die paar Bitcoin Spender die bei mir aufgeschlagen sind was die eigentlich für Transaktionsgebühren zahlt haben.
Navi hat schon begonnen Spende kam schon lange nichts mehr weil es in zu schnell viel zu viel wert ist aber früher die da war der Block ja noch nicht so voll weil das war immer so ein Euro was die gespendet haben oder so eine minimale Summe das war nicht so doll viel ich glaube da ging das wirklich noch billig billig durch.
Das schränkt das natürlich das doch schon stark ein jetzt auf jeden Fall deswegen wie sagt die,
müssen mehr Transaktionen pro Block möglich sein das geht indem sie halt dieses Weg wird mal benutzen auch dann wird das ein bisschen besser und dann in dem für die Zukunft noch da,
Optimierung kommen die halt,
mehr Transaktion wo die Transaktionen durch kleiner werden und so wenn Dennis dann bitte kein Präsident wird.
Unser Präsident,
wenn man schon mal wir wollen auch wir sind ja so bisschen die Spaß der ne ich habe nämlich das schon mal erzählt habe ich erzählt ne.
Und zwar ich dein Ernst jetzt.
Aber aber doch und zwar habe ich mir schon immer so ein bisschen gedacht ich habe ja früher viel mit BitTorrent gemacht und Sohn von dem Bremer kennt ihr den noch oder wissen.
Dr gabs ja mal ein Video von dem ich glaube er war auch ist der Ort ist oder ADHS oder sowieso was ist unter Garantie irgendwas hat er auf jeden Fall seine Witze sind genauso schlecht wie die von Elan mask,
das muss ziemlich ähnlich sein egal ist auch sehr schlauer Typ auf jeden Fall weil er hat ja bitte und gemacht hat.
Ja sich da auch schon Sachen ein verlassen auf Beton und ist ja irgendwie auch so eine Art Mesh network könnte man ja Sager so viele Clients arbeiten miteinander obwohl es ein bisschen dran zentraler Trecker egal aber.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein schlauer Typ und erste Gemeinsamkeit ist jetzt ganz klein aber.
BitTorrent Bitcoin das ist noch ganz klein aber wartet,
so dann eigentlich wollte bremscode wollten BitTorrent 20 machen.
Und in den bitteren 20 wollte er das torrent file das ist ja immer,
du hast ein Gigabyte movie oder was auch immer ja dann wird das ja in so kleine Stücke zerhackt fehlt jedes Ding kriegt irgendwie ein Hash und das kommt in dieses Tauchunfall rein und heißt,
wenn du 100 GB durch die Gegend schieben willst dann wird dein Tauchunfall auch dementsprechend größer weil es halt mehr Teile sind oder du musst die Blockgröße halt anpassen also müsste Rehböcke nehmen was dann aber wieder scheiße ist wenn ein Block kaputt ist weil da muss.
Der ganze Block noch mal übertragen werden und umso kleiner der ist umso weniger muss halt noch mal übertragen also das war halt auf jeden Fall ein Problem und deswegen dachte er sich okay ja macht nicht mehr torrent file mit Hashes sondern er macht sich auch diesen.
Mercury das heißt du hast alle Hashes aber auf zwei Hashes werden,
also so ein so ein Pech warum kann man da Merkel Trier was danach gucken was das ist ist dieser Merkel ist auch genau das,
was bei Bitcoin auch die transactions.
Dann auch in Merkel Trier abgebildet und dann wird nur der Merkel route rothaichner zusagen wird gespeichert und so hatte der der Brain dafür,
BitTorrent 20 was nie gekommen ist hatte der auch woanders schon die zweite Sache wo der sich mit genau dem gleichen Scheiß beschäftigt Datum,
das war ja so 2005 oder so wo er über BitTorrent nachgedacht hat seine Sachen eben.
Bitte im Namen werde ich mich auch erinnern.
Oder habe ich dann irgendwann mal fahren weil ich habe so um die Jahrtausendwende.
Hatte ich zu Hause auch schon meinen meinen Netbeans den Rechner oder was auch immer,
hatte den ja mit mit ISDN Standleitung über IP Set irgendwie am Netz und so weiter bei einem Gast in war ja auch schon mal hatten und und hat ebenfalls meinen mein Festnetz Internet zu Hause ne,
also um die 2000 rum und dann habe ich mit so einer Software rumgespielt dies Mojo Nation,
Gigabyte 20 damit nicht aber so Megabyte auf deiner Festplatte vielleicht war es auch schon Gigabyte sinnvoll,
Storage auf deiner Festplatte,
anbieten und hast du zu seinem muchos verdient das bei dir Sachen gelagert werden kryptographisch du wusstest gar nicht was da drin ist sozusagen sonst Vorgänger von von BitTorrent ja den anderen,
Leute dann runterladen konnten oder du konntest auch Sachen publishen muss es dafür aber dann halt Modus bezahlen dann wurde das so im Netzwerk verteilt und zu auch mehrfach das heißt wenn ein Notruf ausgefallen ist,
dann war das egal weil die Sachen lagen dann auch noch verschlüsselt irgendwo anders das war einfach dieses Motion Techno heißt das hatte auch schon.
So bisschen die Features von BitTorrent dass man Sachen verteilt,
aber gleichzeitig halt schon so Naruto Karin zieht nämlich diese Mojo und.
Ratet mal wer das gemacht hat bremco in der später BitTorrent gemacht hat der hat,
das gemacht so und dann habe ich letztens deswegen war schon mal meine Idee der könnte auch der Macher von von Bitcoin sein sondern habe ich letztens noch mal Mojo Nation nachgelesen mit einem Kumpel und habe,
dann einen Namen entdeckt da müsstest oder mache ich das jetzt mal hier Mojo Nation.
Da stand jedenfalls da dass der das mit einem Typen zusammen gemacht hat genau M-net ist das damals da hat das ja nicht alleine gemacht der bremco sondern hat das mit einem Kumpel zusammen gemachte heißt Soko Willcox umhören.
Und ratet mal was der gerade macht.
Wer hat Z gerade gemacht das heißt der Typ mit dem Balkon vor 15 Jahren ModNation macht hat macht jetzt gerade oder vor ein paar Jahren hat angefangen z-cash zu machen dieses anonyme und und privacy.
Vorbei das ist auch so ein Bitcoin abhängig aber hat sich also es schon,
schon sehr gerne hat aber die Ursprünge sind schon auch noch Bitcoin und mit dem Hut der vor 15 Jahren zusammen dieses Monat gemacht also wenn das nicht deiner Sicht hast du dich schon immer mit zum scheiß beschäftigt hat dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Oder was hast du allein nicht dass er Bitcoin gemacht hat weil nee heißt du das nicht aber es riecht verdammt stark danach finden wir aber auf Niveau,
auf jeden Fall,
ja muss aber auch sein aber die beiden Buddies da vor 15 Jahren sich schon zusammen über über Filesharing,
cryptocurrencies unterhalten haben und das wirklich ein schlauer Typ dieser bramton hat doch letztens gibt auch immer mal wieder so Kommentare ab was bei,
bereuen gerade so abgeht und sagt dir dass es gut was die machen oder,
die erzählen ja scheiße und so und wenn sein Kumpel mit dem man das damals schon gemacht hat und die Butter weiter kennen wenn der dann auch noch z-cash macht basierend auf Bitcoin,
dann BH dass das riecht schon ganz schön finde ich also.
Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung dass der Toshi nakamoto nicht ein einzelner type sondern mehrere dann wird mich auch nicht wundern wenn zumindest die beiden Typen,
Teil davon man wahrscheinlich Wanze sogar noch mehrere weil ich denke dass,
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das einer gemacht hat also weil dafür ist es echt zu gut durchdacht ich glaube schon dass das bestimmt vorher auch schon echt eine Weile im Probebetrieb lief bevor sie das so released haben.
Weil Protokoll mäßig hatte das nämlich wirklich nicht viele Fehler also eigentlich glaube ich abends mal einen Bugfix irgendwie machen müssen weil da irgendwas war,
was ein Protokoll die Software kann der Fehler haben aber das Protokoll an sich war eigentlich stable was sie sich darum einfallen lassen.
Also die Idee die Algorithmen das Hashing und dieses ganze so da ist eigentlich da waren die irgendwie was Großes.
Das ist schon eine ganz schöne Leistung finde ich meine es geht jetzt um 200 Milliarden Dollar die das Bitcoin Netzwerk wert ist und das hat noch keiner kaputt gehackt das Ganze für viele andere Sachen nicht baut nie so viel Wert haben.
Das stimmt allerdings ist die Startup companies EM mitgemacht hat ist Evil Geniuses for better tomorrow,
Zitat ist weil das kommt aus dem Illuminati Spiel von.
Steve Jackson Games.
Was ist das für die Leute die auch Verschwörung stehen und so also da kann man zum ersten Mal forschen was brennt halt sonst so noch gemacht hat in den letzten Jahren,
und der bitte aber auch wieder ein Bitcoin machen oder wie,
Nell Toppits angekündigt seine eigene Währung raus aber das hat das natürlich wieder so ein bisschen Luft aus den aus meinen Segeln genommen wenn er plötzlich jetzt mit einer eigenen cryptocurrency anfängt ja weil macht natürlich deinen keinen Sinn aber.
Ja
na wieso er hat jetzt so sich mitgespielt,
gestern aus Beton bricht zusammen deswegen und und fängt eine neue Währung in Reimann in richtig 1000000 Bitcoin.
Woher weiß man dass das der also den weißt du wieso nicht mal gibt weiß man nicht aber es gibt halt im Zeitraum also.
Inzwischen sind ja 16 halbe oder 16,7 Millionen Bitcoins von diesen 21 Millionen Bitcoins gemeint und damals im ersten Jahr also pro Tag 144 Stück,
mal 50 Blöcke mal 50 Bickmann ich weiß nicht wie das am Tag dann sind 144 x 50.
A5 keine Ahnung also 1000 Bitcoins am Tag oder so reicht ja auch nicht für die Millionen.
Muss einer mal schnell durch welchen Freund 144 x 15 sind die Bitcoins die man damals am Tag verdienen konnte ebenfalls in diesem 2009 da haben nicht so viele Leute gemeint dass er das auf irgendeine,
Mailingliste der Jacke,
Pose dass man jetzt damit machen kann dann auch ein paar Leute mitgemacht aber irgendein Adresse oder irgendein Typ hat wohl so eine Millionen,
von zusammen gesammelt die bis heute nicht bewegt wurden,
sie wohnen nur gemeint sind direkt auf ihrer ersten Adresse liegen geblieben und wurden nie angefasst wird heute und da geht man davon aus dass das Satori nakamoto himself ist und.
Ja verschiedene camuto liegt wahrscheinlich schon seit mehreren Monaten zum afrikanischen Hotelzimmer irgendwie tuttner Badewannen nicht gefunden worden,
die Bitcoins wenn ihr ausgegeben werden kann sein dass wegen da sind auf jeden Fall haben ganz viele Leute Trecker sozusagen auf diese Adresse als wenn auch nur irgendein Satori bewegt wird dann klingelt das sofort überall,
und dann weiß man he's alive,
also 7200 km pro Tag wie lange lief das.
Nordwacht anfangen ab 31 2019 oder so bis.
Heute also nein ich meine diese Milliarde Millionen Billionen Bitcoin 2009 und 1000000 Bitcoin.
Was ist das 7345 Milliarden 365 Tage mal 7000 Bitcoin ja das sind 200 Millionen also es kann locker in dem ersten Jahr da schon gemeint worden sein innerhalb von.
4 5 Monaten von einem also.
14 Milliarden US-Dollar schon geschrieben ob Du demnächst nakamoto der reichste Mann der Welt ist wenn der Kurs auf.
Auf die 40 50000 geht dann hat er mehr als alle Jeff Pesos mit seinen wie viel hatte gerade 100 Milliarden oder was.
Wenn der nicht runter wird kein Gehör,
trainieren alle bin kein Millionär sein kafadan Segelboot nehme,
ja ich merke auch schon bis schon natürlich ein Thema was an irgendwie und unheimlich viel mehr interessiert wenn man irgendwelche hält.
Als nicht nach alter sie irgendwie extrem frustriert ist jetzt so für alle Leute siehst mich ja auch mit ein.
Sonne alle hätten ja alle so auf den Nissan Köln und mal irgendwie 100 € in die Hand nehmen und schon wir alles super aber nicht gemacht.
Blöd halt ne nicht auf Dennis hören ist immer schlecht ist immer schlecht bei der Dennis.
Dieser diese rum Geschichte auch ne.
Wir saufen alle den Rum der Händler sagen uns nee der wird nicht mehr gewartet bald euer ja ja ach geht schon Dennis kauft die zwei Kisten stell ich dir einen Schrank und jetzt.
Was ist heute ist ja auch 111 8045 100 € die Flasche.
Ja klar ich habe 77 Flaschen also 7 x 0,7,
Edeka sanetra Ron Zacapa gekauft und das andere war Centenario 1 Liter und die einen etichetta Negra 0,7 habe ich getrunken dass du da noch ein Tröpfchen drin aber davon habe ich noch genau die Kiste mit den sechs und von dem anderen habe ich noch wirklich eine Kiste und diese eine Flasche noch extra,
und ja Peanuts,
das ist eine Wohnung kaufe ich jetzt auf den Geldspeicher rumkommen,
noch bei keiner Bank kriegst aber auch für diese Flasche nicht als ich glaube.
Also bei Ebay vielleicht Richter 350 300 kriegen aber 500 kriegt man ist immer so gerne hätten aber kriegen tut man das nicht,
ich habe da noch so eine Flasche Whisky die glaube ich jetzt bei 300 6707 ja,
alt Version Solingen Chat und dieses Thema für den Rum oder was für alles ja,
ja überhaupt für alles worüber geredet haben mit mir posten ehrlich gesagt die Leute jetzt zu wenig links in chat das Filter nach alle sind schon danach beklagt euch,
das wie die schon und Erneuerung der neue also dass das jetzt auch unter Etiketten wieder verkaufen hat nichts mehr mit zu tun geschmacklich auch es wirklich nur HD du bist mein Blind das machen oder nicht magst das wirklich.
Zeig mir die hinter gekauft und du glaubst gar nicht wie ein das Gehirn beeinflusst also wirklich also ich würde da nichts drauf geben.
Wir können ja mal eine Flasche aufmachen könnt ihr auswählen.
Audio security.
Jessica Audio-CD oder security.
Platzhalter was hast du gesagt ich kann nicht drüber bewusst gibt Monate Security noch so außer dieses Ding was jetzt eh schon wieder alt ist.
Aber ich muss ja schon sagen dass die Softwarequalität gefühlt bei Apple einfach schon nachlässt ne also muss ich aber letzter Zeit auch sagen aber mehrere Hämmer richtig dicke hemmer in wenigen Wochen das ist schon.
Das haben sie echt sehr langen ja aber ich meine doch gar nicht mal die die Security Geschichten sondern die sind ja auch g****** und dann ist auch irgendwie Ruhe aber das z.b. ich rufe Mail auf und dieser.
Robert bye bye may also bei iOS dreht sich ewig,
und irgendwie rum und macht mich fertig denkst ja okay geht halt um wenig ignorierst einfach machst du zu den Scheiß und dann kommt ein neues iOS Update dann sagen sie haben das jetzt g****** mit den Progressbar weil ich male weil dass du ab und zu nicht beendet wurde,
ich habe den gleichen Tag immer noch es ist wird gar nicht besser geworden dass ich dann bisschen komisch also,
sagen sie fixen dann Sachen mehr oder weniger genauso scheiße wie vorher,
also irgendwie ist deren testing in der letzten Zeit ich weiß nicht wann vielleicht zu viele Baustellen offen wo sie da alles irgendwie.
Wir könnten so iOS könnte auch mal so 10 aber irgendwie Verlagen absolut mein iOS also mein iPhone ist jetzt wieder benutzbar immerhin,
hättest so nach diversen Updates also ich kann telefonieren ohne neu zu starten und discrecion auch nur ganz selten nur noch Apps und alles jetzt wieder im benutzt Bahnbereich aber.
Geil ist auch anders und dann hier warum ich jetzt dieses Thema der überhaupt angeschrieben hat S-Bahn hat sich dieser root Login der irgendwie,
also grandios verkackt weil da gab es ja auch einen schönen Artikel nimmst du jetzt eigentlich eine Muffin für die Idee ist nicht gesehen haben wo analysiert wurde wo sie den weiß nicht.
Jesse Stone auf gleich retrace DJ Sunny durch Kiste,
sondern auf die Stelle gefunden haben wo sie sagen dann das Passwort was nicht stimmt dann einfach geschrieben wird in das nicht existierende Passwort und ja dass man sich dann falschen Passwort als Router einloggen kann und so oder mit gar kein Passwort,
also dann ist es das Ding war wohl das irgendwie wenn der root account überhaupt erst aktiviert wurde wenn du dich versucht hast als root anzumelden,
aus irgendeinem Grund weil sie den den WLAN Code von der einen Funktion falsch ausgewertet haben,
was dazu führte dass er,
und wenn du noch mal gedrückt hast dann hat er ja jetzt ist er da Passwort ist nicht gesetzt alles klar du bist drin fertig dann warst du gut und dann das auch noch über Remote.
Für bestimmte Dienste das fand ich das fand ich auch relativ heftig aber zum Glück nicht für SS habe es ist root root login is disabled ne gegenüber sunshine.
Screensharing war das ja aber muss man aus alles auch per Default alles aus ne zum Glück.
Bei den Leuten ja alles ist ja jetzt bin,
echter dumm gelaufen auf jeden Fall so ich meine das kann auch mal passieren und interessant fand ich dann halt,
wieder dass es ihm gelungen ist das A relativ schnell zu fixen und dass er dann zweite Mal ja auch schon die totale maximale Sicherheit Reißleine gezogen haben und so ein Force Update raus gehauen haben es hat keine 24 Stunden gedauert ne.
Ich weiß noch wie es glaube ich an hast du nicht mehr alle am Freitagabend glaube ich oder was an dem Samstag oder nächsten Tag war schon g******,
angeblich in der Bug Report von demjenigen der is reported hat irgendwie zwei Wochen in dem Entwicklerforum von Apple fest länger sogar noch,
ist es irgend jemandem aufgefallen ist dass das vielleicht mal jemand irgendwie sehen sollte der Ahnung hat.
Was heißt sie lesen ihre Apple Forum selber nicht die pfeifende Nichtrauchergesetz Forum und Backbord zwei Sachen nicht mehr irgendwo anders wird aber auch normale Leute können kein Brot machen,
die haben Forum,
wo sollen wir dann diesen backen ja aber so ein Forum kannst du nicht scannen nach allen möglichen esoterischen antworten was unter Umständen vielleicht irgendwann mal irgendwo funktioniert hat auf irgendein System von dem du nicht weißt welchen Zustand ist sich zu dem Zeitpunkt also das kann ich schon verstehen dass es so durch so ein Forum,
jetzt nicht unbedingt es ist ja auch nicht so durch das Forum bekannt geworden sollen jemand ist das aufgefallen hat dann danach gesucht und ist dann auf diesem Forum Eintrag,
wo das jemand einfach so geschrieben hat somit ja ich habe das mal ausprobiert das hat funktioniert dann meldet er gesagt er kommt nicht mal in dein Rechner an und hat jemand anders gesagt er hier macht doch das Sohn sie hat keine Lösung für Problem von jemand,
immer ehrlich hast du denn vielleicht denkst du nur so etwas die Leute an sich für immer sie,
für ein Scheiß erzählen mal einloggen und dann soll es geben,
aber nicht so ganz geschnallt habe ob es denn nun wirklich auch ein,
back failing gab was ignoriert wurde also ein richtiger Radarbilder nichts von diesen toptop normale Leute können kein Radar machen oder,
doch aber du musst den finden der recht gut versteckt,
ich bin sowieso die Didi Hörde Wochenende heutzutage als normaler Mensch als nicht die wellerbau das kann ja halt nun auch mal sein ja so ein.
Report net ziemlich hoch und dann denke ich die meisten Leute ja dann nicht,
nee ich glaube du brauchst einen gebrauchten Developer Account na zwar keinen bezahlten aber.
Aber mal so eine Seite wo man da aber das ist auch ganz sinnvoll dass er schon mal so Leute rausfällt dass es dir zumindest in der Lage sind auch.
Na ja aber dann komme ich auch nicht an und der hier wäre vielleicht ein Kandidat gewesen hätte hätte Fahrradkette ist ja rausgekommen nicht dass du trotz.
Mich geil,
da kannst du halt um die Professoren einbauen wie du willst die irgendwie SecureCode dann hast du nicht was machen und dann zweimal return im Login Screen und ist rot ist auch doof,
dass du ein Screensaver vorne waren der wollte ein Passwort eingeben,
aber ist doch so alt aber Mac OS aber hatte seinen sein den Fokus nicht in diesem Feld und dann kam das dahinter in seinem Fleck Fenstern sein ganze Firmengruppe wie auch immer in black hat sein Passwort am biesenberg hatte ich vor.
Filme.
Ich kann aber wie kriegt man den Fokus von dem Screensaver den ganz schon paar mal beim Lockscreen dass ich getippt habe und dann ist es in den Chat oder so,
lege das Handy noch nicht weiß jemand wie man da sein Fokus weg kriegen sollte es nicht absichtlich mal gib mir und tippt passiert nichts und dann irgendwann mit der Maus ins Feld,
noch mal richtig eingeladen See.
Oh ja jetzt noch Hallenbad ändern,
aktiv wirklich einige Teile des Codes wirklich maintain oder ob dann,
was falsch gemacht wird und dann wieder drin erscheint also du brauchst nur eine Apple ID und Back zu fallen nur ich habe es gerade mal ausprobiert.
Okay das reicht doch also ist ja quasi jeder navi na ja.
Aber jetzt bei Olivier wieder kommt dann mit der sicherlich was kannst du noch für Bagger dass man in die anderen die euch so entsetzt haben was war denn der da was hat der denn für eine Ursache Datum in Datumswechsel.
Doch kein free signals war so ein permanenter wiesborn von dem also often auf dem iPhone auf die was war das 6. Dezember morgens 6 Uhr.
Beim Datumswechsel ist bei.
Gräten wo Apps installiert waren die local notifications aktiviert haben Grad dieser Fehler auf also ist jetzt auch gehen.
Jeder Fehler gewesen sein musste ein spezielle Art von subnautica ringlotte notification also irgendwie sowas wo eine App sagt jeden Morgen um 6 Uhr Klingel hier sowie wecker oder so.
Wobei vielleicht ist der Wecker ja auch eine recurring local notification das bei jedem passiert irgendwie wecker anhatte das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz genau ich werde auf jeden Fall irgendwie nicht von betroffen,
werden auf jeden Fall beim fixen dieses rudebikes auch gleich noch irgendwas im Filesharing wieder zerschossen gehabt oder dann irgendwie auch noch gleich wieder reportet,
unser homekit.
Remote homekit ausgeschaltet weil sie überhaupt das Problem hatten dass es ein anderer Angriff gab mit dem man über homekit gesteuerte Zugangstür Schlösser öffnen konnte.
Remotemouse.net das war jetzt irgendwie auf ein paar Tagen.
Das ist auch ein Security Bug.
Ja und dann haben sie dann haben sie halt dieses gesamte remote homekit erstmal ausgeschaltet.
Ich weiß nicht ob sie's jetzt inzwischen schon wieder eingeschaltet haben aber was ich auch nicht.
Innere begrenztes homekit das furchtbar.
Bei mir hat's jetzt eine Weile lang funktioniert das habe ich irgendwie drei neue homekit Geräte hinzugefügt dann zuerst mal wieder Chaos dauert paar Wochen bis ich es hin optimiert hat.
Da so vieles nicht zu sagen zu Apple Sicherheitslücken außer dass man sich über 23 Maxi sofort g****** wurden aufregt also in meinem Zimmer sein,
Asus Padfone auch nicht,
cool was gebracht was hat's gebracht wie was hat also was hat es geändert na auf 11,
Weibern 11111 11 oder irgendwie so F1 und F2 Wurzel n,
das erste große major update hat dazu geführt dass ich nicht.
Immer neustarten musste mehrmals am Tag und dann einzeln nächsten Patches dann irgendwann war es richtig eingereiht aber trotzdem es war einfach.
Bestimmt Monat unbenutzbar einfach also nur mit großen Schmerzen zu ertragen das war ich schon auch also ist mir vorher einfach nicht passiert.
Ich hatte auch Probleme mit 11,
könntest aber überhaupt nicht an nichts fest machen und zwar war alles nur langsam langsam und dann habe ich Tipp bekommen auf Twitter.
Dass man doch einfach mal und etwas tun sollte vor dem ich bisher immer so ein bisschen Schiss hat um ehrlich zu sein obwohl bei mir nicht so ganz klar was es wirklich so sag mir letzten Sendung sprüht mit dem mit dem alle Einstellung habe ich schon gesagt.
Rasierapparate.
Man sagt immer dass ihr euch auch erkannt.
Der Dennis leider ist die total noch nicht im 21 Jahrhundert gekommen war noch mal eine Schulung ich kann mich ja ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Mein Telefon war langsam und ich habe es dass ich wieder schnell bekommen und du bist einfach mal.
Alle Einstellung wieder so schön heißt gelöscht habe nun bist,
alle einstellungen löschen nicht unbedingt etwas was man gerne macht,
ja also die Definition von alle ist so ein bisschen schwierig und auch die Definition von Einstellung was ist durchaus Einstellung die,
ich unter alle führen würde die ich nicht unbedingt gelöscht haben wollte aber auch,
irgendeinem Grund schafft es alle Einstellungen nur die zu löschen die quasi vom System irgendwie vorgegeben sind.
Oder die das System quasi vorhält.
Die nicht applikationsspezifische das heißt so alleine ganzen settings in deinen Apps die bleiben eigentlich es sei denn es sind halt welche die sie explizit auf System beziehen also sowas wie darf Geolocation verwenden.
Also alle Apps Sachen neu gefragt ob sie meine Position erkennen dürfen alle Apps die Kamera benutzt haben haben nur gefragt ob sie die Kamera benutzen dürfen diese ganzen Freigaben die musste ich alle wieder neu machen,
aber Kita im Blick behalten weil iCloud keychain und alles andere war halt genauso keychains,
Softwarequalität nächster Punkt ist einfach immer noch Schrott.
Sind manche Sachen einfach und aus unerklärlichen Gründen nicht.
Manche ohne zu fragen ich habe irgendwie seit ich hatte bei meinem Clean Install den ich gehe mal gemacht hatte hatte ich noch meine alte keychain rüberkopiert ne.
Also als OLED Login keychain nur um Sachen nachzugucken falls die noch irgendwie brauche weil man kann ja auch keine keychains zusammenführen,
oder na also es geht ja alles nicht so und jetzt habe ich es ja eigentlich leer gemacht damit mich keine Software mehr danach fragen also genau das erste war ich habe das,
alte die alte kitchen.
Mit dem neuen Passwort versehen damit ich zumindest für beide keychains das gleiche Passwort fahren muss und mir nicht noch das alte merken muss ne so.
Hat auch erstmal getan aber es gibt jetzt so zwei drei Passwörter die aus unerfindlichen Gründen immer noch auf diese alte Kitchen zugreifen und immer noch das alte Passwort wollen.
Obwohl ich für die ganze Kita in gesagt habe neues Passwort und natürlich also ja mein Passwort Obi Kitchen zu öffne,
Hey soll ich noch nie gehört,
Zurich,
DJ Passwort für diese alte Keating geändert wurde.
So dann dass ich mir okay kein Bock auf diesen Scheiß ich lösche das jetzt aus der alten keychain damit er dann noch mal das neu anlegt und meine neuen hoffentlich und auch über iCloud gesund.
Was passiert ich lösche autorisiere neu.
Planet-wissen.de hätten kitzeln er fragt mich nach wie vor nach dem alten Passwort und es ist auch nicht in der iCloud,
Hallo Judith signtool alleine da kann ich dir einen Roman schreiben wie also was ich das schon für verzweifelst Anfälle bekommen habe,
mich auch so kurz davor einfach alles wegzuschmeißen und noch mal eine ganz frische Kitchen anzufangen der alte Mann.
Ticketeria schon graue Haare überall am Kopf das ist.
Wolltest du mich darauf hinweisen dass man meine grauen Haare sieht.
Was meinst du die Stimme der Jugend ja natürlich ist hier die Stimme auch nur ein verzweifelt versuche meinen Stuhl noch zu sichern,
der hat sich nicht funktioniert hätte ja natürlich Natur Haarfarbe blau,
denn du bist die Stimme der Jugend du bist ja noch kein draufgekommen bestimmt hin.
David Gabi,
Hallo wir machen senil.
Im Fahrstuhl.
Wird schwierig ich bin so halt ich darf dass das man heute,
Milch wie lange darf man nicht in die andere importieren kann das nervt mich auch jedes weil ich auch immer beim beim Rechnerwechsel eigentlich auch immer die Kita Villa rüberziehen loslassen.
Das und dann die Einträge ja da musst du Fäden einzeln eingeben also jetzt habe ich auch schon probiert.
Also hallo Alexander wollte welche auf meiner alten löschen damit die mal weg sind besser zum Fenster so delete ne kam nicht,
tausendmal probiert Neustadt macht plötzlich auf einmal ging's,
Design oder so Logikfehler oder oder 1000er schulterzuck Fehler also ich habe das Gefühl die Kids shiny wurde seit 13 Jahren nicht mehr angefasst und,
bitte ja,
ja aber nicht jetzt sich nicht signifikant handy app oder cicely das Konzept ich meine mit der iCloud keychain haben sie das,
und dann noch mein lieblings keychain Fehler seit 10 5.
515 verliebte Lieblingsdesign Fehler seit 10 15 die einen Passwort vorschlagen lässt von der Kiefer hat es auch schon mal,
mit dem seit zehn 5l dass das haben sie nach wie vor auch in 10.13 nicht g****** er nimmt immer das gleiche nein,
er macht ja macht ja so Passwort Vorschläge ne Wortzahl Sonderling noch mal ein Wort und die Wörter die holt aus irgendeinem,
Wörterbuch.
Und dieses Wörterbuch hat ein Problem mit dem encoding so dass sämtliche deutschen Sonderzeichen ä und ö und scharfes S falsch codiert werden,
er zeigt an die falsche codierten Zeichen aber nicht an und du merkst es nur dass entweder das Wort so aussieht wie das ist doch kein deutsches Wort,
da fehlt doch ein Buchstaben oder aber du gehst mit dem Cursor so eine Taste nach der anderen durch und wenn er in irgendeiner Lücke zwischen zwei Buchstaben zweimal stehenbleibt wert,
dann ist genau da die Buchstaben V,
ich habe auch eine Weile lang habe ich zu jeder Major Release dann noch mal zu dazu geschrieben dass es noch nicht g****** ist,
aber das habe ich mir jetzt irgendwann dann habe ich das mal aufgegeben ich meine.
Wir haben ja schön ihre Colonel panics irgendwie eingesammelt wahrscheinlich nach Inzidenz irgendwie sortiert nach der Menge und von oben halt dann die schlimmsten abgearbeitet und ich muss da Sandkörner Penis habe ich schon jetzt ewig nicht mehr gesehen seit Jahren kann ich wirklich Paul.
Aber so die normalen Logik Bugs dass irgendwas nicht so zusammen spielt wie sollte das kriegen wir irgendwie nicht g****** und dann wird es wahrscheinlich auch,
sieht man ja diesen Bug Reporter das verstehen halt einfach nicht das kannst du doch gar nicht so gut erklären weil so komplexe Dinger kann man den ja gar nicht beschreiben so komisch wie das ist oder so nah.
Das Problem ist auf jeden Fall merklich dass sie irgendwie immer versuchen neue Features irgendwie runter einzubauen und unterzubringen aber nicht so,
wie kann funktioniert so richtig warten und noch mal durchchecken und keine Ahnung und auch was was so teilweise you are you X angeht und Gesten auf dem Telefon dass das.
Immer mehr immer mehr reingepackt wird aber nicht drüber nachgedacht wird was eigentlich wirklich Sinnvolles.
Was man halt so überfrachten von ach guck mal da kannst du noch mal nach links wischen dann kannst du ja nach rechts wischen darf man oben nach unten und davon was ich links unten aus dem Bildschirm nach oben rechts und sie denkt sie so.
Ja
und aus Versehen drüber gewischt ist dann wieder irgendwas anderes an das Bild selber nicht merkt wenn Programm im Hintergrund plötzlich sagt dass es jetzt mal den Fokus haben will was so wahrscheinlich passiert mir das Programm sagt gib mal Focus und der Screensaver ja das alles noch so ein.
Standard Framework der gibt dann halt einfach sein Fokus weg weil er ja darf man halt so machen.
Mein Sohn ist mit nicht mehr die dicken Funktionalitäten es gibt eine erschweren den Faktor das hat sich die Tatsache dass ich jetzt in zunehmenden Maße dieses ganze US und das was es tut.
In hohem Maße abhängig macht von dem Zustand des Netzes auf das ist trifft und das ist natürlich auch nicht so ohne weiteres testbar.
Du kannst natürlich immer von irgendeinen bestimmten Internet ausgehen aber im Prinzip oder was heißt im Prinzip,
tatsächlich hat es natürlich unendlich viele Zustände jedes überhaupt gar nicht testen kannst das heißt du kannst eigentlich die Software im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes nur noch beim,
Kunden reifen lassen weil du nur dann auch die Bedingungen findest oder den du das Testen kannst egal wie viel testen aarios Attest oder aufsetzen,
kannst halt ausrechnen ob auch eine Funktion nach wie vor,
53 plus 7 Rechner kann ja.
Softwarequalität Moment Stopp ein einfach klaut dieser jetzt mit reingekommen ist iCloud und auch dieses ganze,
diffuse Input Gewalt mit künstlicher Intelligenz und machine learning geht das Herz im Prinzip genauso weiter.
Ist die Frage wie gut funktioniert meine Tastatur prediction wie gut.
Funktioniert Siri etc das alles Dinge die sich eben über die Zeit auch ändern also du heute kannst du sagen ja das funktioniert nicht.
Und dann hast du den Podcast veröffentlichen auf einmal funktioniert wunderbar.
Allein weiß dann irgendwie danach noch mal 2000 das ausprobiert haben und damit das Training vorangekommen ist will sagen ich bedauere das auch.
Dass wir so einsam. Sind das.
Dass ich Software wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so richtig testen lässt.
Weiße sich ebenso sehr aufs Netz ein bist andererseits,
schaffen sie jetzt nicht online dass ich finde das ist also hier der Taschenrechner das beste Beispiel für,
sogar Software aktiv kaputtmachen und überhaupt nicht checken weil sie anscheinend nicht mal selber einmal diese scheiß Taschenrechner App aufmachen und überhaupt testen ob der plus,
irgendwas funktioniert Fritz auch total sonnenklar was da kaputt ist ja sie warten irgendwie nicht auf das Feld von dem Backen oder sie warten auf das Pferd von Bad und dann ist 1 + 2 + 3 XL 24.
Und du fängst jetzt ne nein hier.
Und ich meine wie lange ist das schon so ein riesen Paket iOS also bestimmt ist zwar schon in 10 so oder der Taschenrechner haben sind 11 Semester.
Ja eben das halt auch so rüber scheiße und jetzt ist es ist halt Refactoring,
Bärbel muss man doch mal ausprobieren sorry ich habe dafür nicht so wirklich Verständnis bei mir,
0 g Netz in Swift neu zu schreiben.
Und dann verkacken sind auch nananana gibt er bessere Tools wo sich lohnen würde dass ich mal 20 von Grund auf neu zu machen also 1 + 2 + 3 = 24 + 2 + 3 = 6.
Hast du ein 11.2 schon etwas ist jetzt gerade rausgekommen 11211 noch nicht wie gibt's das auch da kommt gerade ich update gerade.
1 + 2 + 3 ist bei mir auch 6,
Ledersitze langsam,
Officer ich habe keine Ahnung,
ich habe 11 wo was ich habe 11 11 12 weil ich natürlich ist mit 11 schon g****** Frankfurt ja OKEY OKEY auf dein Argument warum ist das neu.
Weil das Spiel genau das was hier passiert ist ja also wir haben in Swift s9711 ihrer Tools genommen.
Habe ihr eigenes Hundefutter ausgepackt und angefangen ist zu essen und jetzt habe ich auch festgestellt dass da was schief gegangen ist bei kann ja sehr wohl sein.
Dass der Bug in irgendeiner Form mit Swift libraries Event keine Ahnung hast du nicht gesehen wer zu apologetisch unterwegs und so Apologeten Firma die irgendwie so ne,
Power hat irgendwie bei einem simplen schon im Taschenrechner verkackt im 21 Jahrhundert wirklich nicht dafür habe ich keinerlei Verständnis 00.
Absolute 0,0.
Nein ich krieg nein ich kann heute als ich kann weil wir haben das dann Fehler erzeugt und gefunden also wie viel Monate später hätte erst draußen auf.
War ja jetzt auch nicht so schlimm ist ja jetzt nicht so dass das Apple finanziell kurz vor dem Ruin steht also man hat so das Gefühl die haben einfach Kosten eingespart bei ihrer testabteilung.
Weil vorne und hinten Die peinlichsten Bugs auftreten also das kann einfach nicht sein.
Aber dieses mit den Buttons hatte ich vor vor seinem 1 x 25 Jahren auch schon auf dem Amiga,
Button geklickt hast du hast gesehen wie er sich so.
Grafisches Dingens also das halt gedrückt wurde wurde graphisch irgendwie visualisiert in dem sich das 3D Dingsda geändert hat damals hat bei der mit 3D und wieso macht ihr wisst schon mit dem Licht von.
Der Klick nicht durchkomme ich dachte wie kann es sein dass er mir visualisiert dass ich mir klicke bei sich sehr dass ich ihn geklickt habe aber gleichzeitig war ich anzeigen,
anscheinend zu schnell dass er auch wirklich das Ding als Klick.
Annimmt das habe ich schon damals nicht verstanden das scheint jetzt ein ähnlicher wachsen seine oder ihre sehen dass Sie geklickt hat aber es kommt trotzdem nicht durch naja dann halt noch auf den Fehler oder so bevor.
Es ist also alles mein Pascal egal mach mal.
IOS F21 umfasst Fehlerbehebung und behebt unter anderem ein Problem bei dem der entfernte Zugriffe gemeinsame benutze der home App die Karte aktiviert wurde.
Dass er der bugfilet Homepage also stand ja auch da.
Dann doch eher zu den positiven Sachen bei den letzteren Updates irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob das schon mit 11 km oder jetzt auch mit F1 oder F2 aber habt ihr schon mal in dem Laden gesessen ihr wolltet das wlan Passwort haben.
Und dann ist bei eurem Kumpel nebenan der auch gerade mit dem Telefon rumspielen dann das so ein so ein so ein Popup Dinge zukommen dass hier der will das Passwort wollt ihr dem das geben und dann sagst du jetzt und dann kommt das automatisch an und du musst nichts machen.
Ja ist eigentlich ziemlich cool,
aber erst die Telefone müssen irgendwie dicht beieinander liegen dass ich glaube es braucht Bluetooth oder so damit die sich sehen das ist ja nicht NFC ist ja nur,
passiv oder der macht das ja nicht aktiv ne also das Bluetooth und das,
hätte ich ja alleine die gesagt okay bluetooth ist toll aber das bluetooth alleine reicht nicht sondern die andere Person die müssen sich auch noch,
ich weiß nicht gegenseitig aber dumm ist der der das Passwort rausrücken soll der muss dich wo du das haben willst also die Apple-ID muss irgendwie in den Kontext an die mit drin sein sonst.
Kommt dieses Derrick Westerland nicht der das über mit den Kanaren.
Zimmer nicht sicher inwiefern das noch von WLAN abhängig ist und der so eine ähnliche Methode benutzt wie.
Was ist nur bei Blut oder ist es bei WLAN äh wenn die Apple watch das Unlock macht das hat quasi die nackte Wahrheit.
Ja beides müsste die Distanz ja damit du keinen damit du also zu mir zumindest so ein verlängerungs Angriff nicht so einfach ist.
Ja weil du müsstest ja dann beide Frequenzbänder bidirektional verlängern und das ist natürlich ein heiden Aufwand.
Bootmanager mittelzeh schwierig weil es ja dann einfach Latenzen erzeugt und genau dann funktioniert ja nicht.
Ja aber die Latenzen selber die kannst du glaube ich über Sonnensystem gar nicht so genau messen also mit diesem komischen Autoschlüsseln funktionierte das ja auch.
Immer wieder das dass du dass du einfach nur die Funkreichweite verlängert.
Und aber dadurch dass du seit über zwei getrennte Systeme machst und wahrscheinlich auch wann ich was wohin und über welches Band schicke völlig iratisch ist kannst du das halt durch den einfachen.
Hardware hack also jetzt unreinen analogen Heck glaube ich einfach nicht mehr richtig machen.
Na auf jeden Fall ist es ein schönes User Feature gar keine Frage funktioniert natürlich dann auch für einen selber ganz gut das heißt was neues WLAN-Passwort und wie auf dem Mac eingegeben und dann kannst du so wie schon auf deinen.
Telefon ich habe es glaube ich mit mir wann das ist wieder was anderes zu der valadier sind die die Person die das war nicht gesund sein ich hatte so ein Dialog mit Schwung wie willst du das übertragen und dann ja dann war es auf meinem Telefon.
Ja sag deiner public WiFi sollte Passwort frei sein ist natürlich Unsinn.
Weil,
dann ist ja alles unverschlüsselt und dann überträgst du im Klartext das wird sehr gute Brillen alle im selben key verwendet auch nicht viel gewonnen.
Also ich kann ja das Congress Center Bein ich auch gerne man sich sozusagen seinen key selber wählen kann und der nimmt halt einfach jeden aber hat dann trotzdem encrypted Session Folgen auf super.
Verstehe nicht warum es nicht so ein WiFi Modus geben kann wo das einfach steinalt ist dass ich einfach jeder sein eigenes Ding aus würfelt und fertig,
macht halt einfach public access dir selbst Signal sicher du suchst dir selber aus und nimm mir einfach dran teil,
Oma gibt gar kein Passwort an sondern quasi mit dem Logon auf das Netzwerk wird leicht klar dass man sich selber Anschlüsse gibt und fertig ist die Laube,
Motorleistung message von Clemens mit RFC Nummer hast du nicht gesehen XYZ,
gibt's schon im Mai verstanden hat müsste nur im Vergleich brummte telefoniere gut,
aber na ja na ja gibt noch viel Raum für Verbesserung aber das ist auf jeden Fall ja sage ich auch in meinem Kurs sicherheit geht so das irgendwie die Frage und wenn ihr dann in eine neue Wohnung zieht oder irgendwie so temporär und ihr seht im Hinterhof revised freut ihr euch dann ja und,
dunnerkeil.
Kann man das Konzept von Honeypots erklären ja wie man sozusagen sich den ganzen Traffic Nachbarschaft,
war schön auf den Rechner holen kann ja also wenn du wirklich.
Transparente Statistik über die Bundesrepublik Deutschland erholen willst dann machst du halt einfach ein paar Hotspot unter dem Namen Telekom auch,
das ist auch dass das auch bis heute noch nicht g****** ist das da war keine entsprechende.
Public Key Absicherung gibt WLAN zu einem spricht das finde ich irgendwie haarsträubend ehrlich Mahlzeiten zu Hotspot,
auf der so alle.
Namen trägt die so gemeinhin wo sich jeder schon mal irgendwie eingeloggt hat von Starbucks Hilfe McDonald's Leben Telekom uzara Tabletten an alle Telefone drin hängen und,
am Ende machen wir gleich noch ein Auto Login und Hamburg gar keine Möglichkeit zu merken dass das eben nicht die Seite ist wo man das.
Zum Autolack in Essen immer wieder auf mit dem ich habe die hat ja so ein simlock,
bitte laden Sie diese Telekom Sim Netz und da findet dann die Authentifizierung ja über die SIM-Karte Stadt das ist ja ganz sinnvoll,
wertvoll,
bitte mal ein Tool gehackt das hieße Peak.
Ja also eigentlich ist das von diesen Store Tschechei von dem der Clemens auch immer erzählt habe ich dass sie es eigentlich mal,
Isa Isa pack das nämlich Gifs daraus gefiltert hat,
also es ist von diesem Typen der dabei Apple hier später für Netzwerk und Rondo du entwickelt hat ihren Opa Netzwerkkarte und so können wir ja schon einmal auf der Welt den Typen die haben das eigentlich gekotet das waren noch zu zu Mac OS.
Also,
uralt letztes Jahrtausend auf jeden Fall und ich habe das nur in Objective-C irgendwie umgeschrieben,
was hat er denn Image keinen Bock dass es nicht nur gibt's kann sondern alles was dieses Image schreiben kann kann halt also auch BMPs und PNGs und beiße nicht und habe das dann so gemacht also um das Nummer zu erklären das Tool hat.
Was hat das eigentlich mit dem habe ich die Netzwerkschnittstelle irgendwie gegeben der hat Pakete mit geknüpft und hat.
Die die die tipeeestream wieder zusammen gesetzt hat da drin im Original nach den gif Markern gesucht also später dann nach den PNG ist und Jetpack und weiß nicht was alles so durch geflogen ist,
und hat die Bilder dann Imsum Imsum View in so einem Interview irgendwie angezeigt und so durch gescrollt und dann habe ich noch so eine Art dB rangemacht das immer so die letzten 100 Bilder.
Insos leider sehen und her scrollen konntest also,
L und die letzten 100 im Slider genau und das war dann immer so schöne demone hast du dann auch so einem offenen WiFi oder sonstwo deinem hab oder wo auch immer.
Luisa pick noch mit Monitor schön gestaltet hast dann halt so die Gedanken da Bilder durch und damals war ja noch nicht soviel verschlüsselt wie heute.
Das ging und ich glaube das Coolste was wir gemacht haben war irgendwie 2002 oder 1 oder so auf dem Kongress.
Darf ich dann dann meinen du LG 4 mit 500 Megaherz und auf dem Kongress geschleppt.
Habe den Jungs gesagt ey ich brauche mal den mirror Port vom Uplink irgendwie hier zu meinem Rechner schicken bitte,
habt ihr eine rein gestartet habe das ist apk Stadt und dachte es wird jetzt alles zusammenbrechen aber es hat halt gerockt und verformt und die ganze Zeit Kreutner hält die die Bilder durch was die Leute das gemacht haben und dann fing die auch an ne dadrüber.
Am I too ich Porno Mädchen zu machen und und sind dann nach vorne, hier ist mein Bild und so was er gerade gesagt hat,
dann haben sie angefangen irgendwie Bilder zu machen wo Sprüche drin stand und dann haben sie irgendwann angefangen über dieses Ding zu chatten weil man das denn dann so da sehen konnte und so und das war sehr witzig das noch habe ich das auch immer so weil,
Beständen Andernach immer mal so Laptop und Telefon auf und wann immer schön indem Hotspots in dem Zimmer drin da konnte man dann.
Selber mit reinsetzen maletas Malbec mir sozusagen die Verschlüsselung und dann kann ich mal so eine zeichnen im auf dem Beamer Qualität Bilder anzeigen das war auch ein großer erinnert sie gesagt wo alles https verschlüsselt es gibt immer seltener,
aber wie ich erst letztens wieder erfahren musste ich frage ja mal so was macht er denn da so eine SSL Warnung im Browser kommt oder so Zertifikat waren die weg,
ja gibt's immer noch auf die Seite ich klicken weiter.
Insofern war das immer noch funktionales Tool baut nicht mehr.
Welches ist schon lange nicht mehr also eigentlich.
Mir wurde aber auch nicht mehr gehen wirklich also es wirklich alles Krypton Zeug und auch die Sessions mit keep-alive und so geht das ja dann auch nicht mehr so richtig schick und deswegen das Pack nichts mehr gebracht am Ende.
Aber da gibt's bestimmt andere Tools die das machen die dann das SSL wenn ich dazwischen hängen oder wie auch immer die dann das auch besser da diese Streams wieder zusammenkleben.
Ja war es hat Spaß gemacht auf jeden Fall,
sowieso so eine schöne Zeit auch noch so die alten wardriving WLAN Antennen durch Berlin gefahren ist mit so diversen KFZ um nach Wien auf den WLAN zu suchen.
Ja ja.
Wenn du die Stimme der Jugend vom Krieg erzählt ich wollt gerade sagen dass du meine,
ja wir werden Sie sich jetzt für die Freakshow das Leben brauche dringend eine Verjüngungskur,
hihihi ja wisst nicht.
Kongress hat da jemand noch was beizutragen vielleicht den unterwegs.
Bitte diesen mobil unterwegs.
Wie mobil muss sein ändern.
Ach so na ja also Tretroller sind glaube ich so das Minimum Elektroroller wollen sie irgendwie nicht zulassen zu meiner Größenbestimmung.
Rentner welche Veranstaltung sich der eingedreht das weiß ich noch nicht aber ich werde ihn auf jeden Fall erstmal mitnehmen als auch,
Fahrrad.
Nee aber ich habe ja sowohl innen als auch einen außen Bedarf weil ich muss ja auch noch irgendwann mal das Gelände verlassen unten außen Fahrrad das war so der Gedanke.
Nee also eigentlich bringt nichts dagegen das Fahrrad mitnehmen also.
Wieso willst du dann mal fahren nee weiß ich habe mich von diesem Klapprad Gedanken ja abge das habe ich jetzt,
ja aufgegeben weil ich Herz wenn es Wetter gut ist mit dem Rennrad bis nach Wannsee fahren dann nach Potsdam weiter also nee was andersrum,
ich mache mir aber nicht auf Leipzig bis nach Wannsee mit der S-Bahn und fahre von dort dann nach Potsdam reden gerade vom Kongress ne,
nee Weilrod ihr fragt nicht ok Google.
Habe ich schon so also ich weiß auf jeden Fall,
noch mal die Liste von verbotenen Dingen nicht ab da stand irgendwie gleiche der Kokain wenn man sich so ganz sicher,
also ja dass das besser ist muss mir jetzt nicht erzählen aber leichter brennen gibt es unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber.
Nein nein ich meine Person Faultier mit ich möchte den potentiellen Teilnehmer,
Kongresses jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel sagen da wo er was geht oder nicht geht weil,
ich habe so das Gefühl das werden die dann irgendwie selber rausfinden,
wie eine wie auch die andere Richtung alles mitgehört mal sehen was passiert.
Humanoide Roboter der jetzt schon in Edewecht.
Zehnkämpfer.
Ihr wisst schon der ist jetzt auch der ist erste Mal so ein so ein so ein Backflip gesprungen ist im Urlaub war geil der Backflip war geil,
das ist Gary aber geil unten schwimmt immer noch laut,
na ja wenn man den also rumlaufen lassen würde und mit einer Rikscha irgendwie durch die Gegend laufen würde es will,
die gegen auf dem Kongress durch die Gegend fahren dann auch gleich das auf seinen Schultern durch die Gegend tragen lassen das dafür besser willst du viel zu groß Plasten Krach gefährlich.
Lastenkraxe Katze verstanden deswegen Kraxe ist so eine Art.
Kakao Rucksack der aber nur aus einem Metallgestell besteht hinten einsetzen wo du Holzscheite Holzscheite oder Kohle heißt das.
Was heißt Kraxe keine Ahnung ich kenne das nur.
Unter dem Titel vielleicht ist das ein süddeutsch bayrischer Ausdruck.
Rücklage weitergeleitet von Kraxe.
Rücken tragen bei der wichtiges Transportmittel für Hausierer Buckel Krämer sowie in der Landwirtschaft na ja.
Beruflich waren unter anderem Uhrenträger und Glasträger auf Rücken tragen angewiesen.
Weil die Uhren so schwer früher der Boston Dynamics Buckel Träger bequemer ist doch warte mal was wie was Uhrenträger.
Dass Leute die Minderung gelaufen sind.
Schwarzwalduhren auf Rücken tragen damit so ein Sync zwischen den ganzen Dörfern stattfinden kann.
Jetzt einmal hört die Uhr von einen Orden nächsten getragen konnte mal jede man wieder die Uhren erstellen dann.
Wieso steht denn in der Wikipedia indem man die Kanone gefeiert wird ist Unterführung.
Berufe die Wikipedia auch folgende Artikel zu verbessern Buckel Apotheke.
Die ausschließlich olitäten anbieten das heißt ich kann ein zagadou buckelapotheker und das ist nicht mal eine Beleidigung.
Weil wenn du es so sagst wie du es gerade gesagt hast wird es vielleicht beleidigend aufgenommen also ich meine wir starren hier gerade auf diese Fotos auf den Wikipedia-Artikel Buckel,
Träger was wirklich unfassbar ist unter anderem dieser Glas Verkäufer das erinnert mich irgendwie fatal an diese Currywurst Verkäufer auf dem Alexanderplatz komplettes Currywurst Produktions oder hottenträger ja das sind dann auch,
doppelträger wie heißen die doch gleich Grillwalker,
so heißen wie heißen die Grillwalker Grillwalker.
Eine Grill Kraxe heißen Grill und interessanterweise gibt's da relativ viele Rollstuhlfahrer da drunter weil die die müssen natürlich nicht tragen aber sie stehen da natürlich quasi trotzdem.
Stimmt,
achso weil sie die Erlaubnis haben das sozusagen deren stehen ja aber im Rollstuhl stattfinden darf weil der Gewinde Mensch da nichts.
Fahrstuhl Rollstuhl dann hast du richtig Comfort brauchst du so dann,
deine Trutzburg quasi in so ein komplett mobiles Currywurst Studio,
du bist kein Anker zeige rollerträger wo der gerade,
von flavour.
Super Wollenweber weitestgehend ohne Geschmack oder wenn ein ganz großes Kino Public Enemy wer das nicht kennt gehört ja nun wirklich zu den,
legendärsten,
Bands der ersten Stunde und Flavor Flav selber ist halt einer davon also check die war ja so der Hauptsänger und Flavor Flav habe ich dir flexibel.
Flavour of love.
Genau der hat halt immer irgendwie so eine fette Uhr um Hals das ist sowieso sein sein sein sein Ding gewesen,
na ja wie gesagt der Welt na ja die haben also einen Achtzigern haben die halt irgendwie richtig losgelegt ne.
Aber er hat auf jeden Fall ja ja der hat gehabt das aber nicht also.
Oder sehen gut aus ja hast du schon Musik Public Enemy number one.
Also und fantastische Texte im übrigen Kasse drehzeug wirklich gut ist nicht so albern der Hip Hop richtig Rap bitte was heißt das weiß auch keiner.
Außer du.
Ich weiß es Flug noch nicht an mir vorbei ist war auch so einen Moment und Erkenntnis Moment wo ich mir dachte so warum weiß ich das nicht schon mein ganzes Leben über sowas du so Begriffe die man immer benutzt und man weiß überhaupt nicht was sie heißen.
Also, nachdenken.
Es ist eine Abkürzung oder Abkürzung Akronym aber nichts bist du sicher dass es nicht in Beck Rindermist.
Dass du jetzt uns jetzt präsentierst rhythm and poetry.
Da würde ich jetzt drauf wetten dass es ein Balkon im ist warum weiß es nachträglich in das überführt wurde ja go head.
Naja muss das ja jetzt auch rückwirkend beweisen weil sonst geht's ja nicht du müsstest aber,
erstmal vorwärts beweisen dass deine ich sahrasunshine öffentlichem Podcast dann stimmt das erstmal so lange bis das Gegenteil,
ey mach hier nicht,
nein das ist alles äußerst sinnvoll,
dann Wikipedia.
Wikipedia steht oder Englisch auf Tour plaudern und schwatzen,
rhythm and poetry naja Riverman Blues also Englisch Rap.
Trap Rap line Prime Rap poetry was.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Florian quatschen Schlag oder überlagert Palaver Schwätzchen,
schwarz Geplapper die Rüge die Kritik.
Auch nicht schlecht der ruf ja ja.
Also von rapucation ich würde auch sagen Essen backhuhn im Rezitation.
Rapucation.
Tja rhythm and poetry.
Neuer ich bin nicht überzeugt ok ich auch nicht mich als überzeugt also wir wollten im Moment das ist ja klar aber ist nicht so was haben wir noch wo wir sind angekommen.
Aber als ich habe aber Kongress wenig zu erzählen über den Charakter mal gedingst und dann sind wir dann gemacht was man nicht,
hatte noch zu besorgen wieso ist jetzt schon zu spät nee aber irgendwann ist zu spät.
Ja also da das Messegelände jetzt ein bisschen weiter weg von der.
Vom Zentrum der Zivilisation ist der dortigen,
genau wurde sich bemüht dass die Straßenbahnlinie die dahin führt auch nachts und in regelmäßigen Takt fährt und,
da gibt es wohl auch ein Übereinkommen mit den Verkehrsbetrieben und das Unterfangen zu unterstützen und das Interesse und die Nachfrage zu erfassen wurde halt gebeten sich schon im Vorhinein nein,
entsprechendes Spezial Ticket zu kaufen.
Was man dann vor Ort mit seinem Bändchen an der Kasse bekommt so dass eben dann irgendwie geklärt werden kann also wie viele Leute sind überhaupt interessiert wie viele Bahn müssen wieder einsetzen ich vermute mal die Werners daneben,
so im Laufe des Tages dann vielleicht auch noch mal also nach dem ersten Tag Zeit immer bisschen anfassen genau und ja deswegen war in dieser Aufruf da kauft euch das jetzt schon mal damit wir Bescheid wissen.
Und dann der LBB.
Nee LVB Bescheid weiß wie viel bahnen und Neutronen Waggons was kann ich wie heißt denn der Leipziger Verkehrsbetriebe bestimmt lvwvg.
Gewerbebetriebe auch BVG und ich BVB.
Hartes Bea dann weiß ich auf jeden Fall schon wird sich ja dann hoffentlich auch noch mal einen Link dazu finden also wenn ihr zum Kongress kommt.
Und vielleicht auch mal das einmal normal ohne KFZ in die Stadt wollt ihr denn eins dabei habt würden ihr dabei habt.
Dann könnt ihr auch euch dann noch dieses Ticket klicken falls ihr das noch nicht habt um die ganze Aktion etwas zu unterstützen.
Sowie.
Bin ich heute vermutlich auch mit der Bahn anreisen das hat sich als in den letzten Jahren als sehr sinnvoll erwiesen.
Denn um das Messegelände ringsrum ist glaube ich auch wirklich so gut wie nichts aus dem Baumarkt nö was natürlich strategisch McDonald's McDonald's Ansfelden.
Schade dass sie in McDonald's ist das Beste vom Besten.
Keine SMS bester ich hab die.
Saini damit er vielleicht mal gucken ja ich habe diese Fototour der auch mal zu Gemüte geführt was kann ich vor Ort,
war noch gar nicht vor Ort aber virtuell halt ne und ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt wie so die Herausforderung angenommen wird aus diesem,
Gebäude das zu machen was wir unter Kongress verstehen.
Also ich bin positiv Hoffnung dass das gelingt aber es ist auf jeden Fall ich meine letzte Mal wurde er gesagt so ein bisschen aber das Gefühl dass die Leute jetzt schon,
das CCH so leer gespielt haben und weil es langweilig war alles schon verstanden,
beim CCL heißt das so leer da gibt's jedenfalls jede Menge.
Weil man schon angefangen von den Vortrag sehen die ja quasi nicht.
Christian die die Existenz Unsinn kann man eigentlich gleich jetzt ungeeignet verwerfen.
Und da es gibt so einiges.
Seit ich bin einfach so mit angespannt auf solche kreativer Umgang mit dem Medium ne neue Baustelle anderer Charme andere.
Ist ja auch nicht so angeranzt jetzt z.b. die Berliner Messe oder der das CCH ist ja schon alles was die Neunziger oder so sieht das so aus auf den Fotos die Neunziger.
About Optiker oder Helm ist frisch gemacht weil er frisch gemacht in den Neunzigern also zahlen ja so einige Sachen so mit diesen,
mindest in die Ausgestaltung seid ein bisschen moderner aus als 70 sicherlich mal was gemacht worden aber im Kern ist das halt alles 70er Jahre alt Uhrglas Dingsbums ist aus den Siebzigern,
diglas Dings Weser großer halbröhre kann so Hauptbahnhof Style die da.
Was willst du von Leipzig ich dachte du bist bei bei Hamburg,
nein du hast natürlich recht es ist alles 20 Jahre alt.
Und ja das Glas denn für die z.b. ist es mal ganz interessant wieso Trenc.
Boden und und und vor allem halt auch so.
Der Wunsch nach der Maschine mit dem Bing ja das Gerät was da steht.
Da ist nichts tut aber mal schöne Töne macht man von der Verwaltung Hindemith Meißen,
das lebensfeuer sie haben auch die Maschine mit dem Ping.
Das ist z.b. diese Glas Wurster in der Mitte ja das ist halt so ein Teil ich meine ist eine glass Wurst sorry ja das ist so,
rückglas Wurst im Gewächshaus halt so ein Gewächshaus hat also einfach eine traumatisch schlechte Akustik.
Alter ich mir auch schon gedacht einfach in jeder Hinsicht genauso schlecht wie man sich das so oder so eine glass Wurst hat heute schlechte Akustik das war der Wiener Hauptbahnhof ist nicht so schlimm aber ich find's ziemlich schlimm ehrlich gesagt doch.
Also also ist kein Vergleich oben auf diesem in diesem Glasrohr das ist ziemlich laut.
Laut und ich sind Nummer zwei ganz andere parallel aber du kannst oeffnen aus dem Glas Konstrukt kannst du nur schwer eine gute Akustik machen die auch.
Ja halt nicht nicht mit der autocut Software der 90er Häuser Tage könnte man halt das mal unter akustischen Aspekten schon mal hammerhart also,
ja du kannst natürlich jede Menge Absorber an guten Stellen einbringen kannst auch am Hauptbahnhof in Berlin eigentlich hätten machen sollen aber dann hat es ja nicht mehr gereicht von der Zeit,
du kannst ja auch Schall brechen der Elemente einbauen indem du halt die Glasform entsprechend anders Design ja auch nicht gemacht.
Nein hast du nicht gemacht weil sie wollten halt einfach nur streite Wurst wie man es halt eine 90er Jahren gemacht hat das war halt so das Teil da haben wir hier so a hier ist die Glashalle so schön aus,
aber leider nicht so Pflanzen oder was anders nee.
Ja da steht super Bäumchen rum und das sind auch so ein paar Funktionseinheiten und dann hast du da irgendwo da würde eine hasse irgendwie noch mal Interesse.
Bereichen und was ist arschkalt ist ein Ding ja.
Kommt ja noch dazu wenn die Sonne steht drauf dann ist sie.
Und kalt ist da halt weil es halt offen ist halt Bescheid nicht wirklich ein geschlossener Bereich,
und das ist halt auch problematisch und das sind natürlich muss ich sagen aus rein ökonomischen Gesichtspunkten ist das halt einfach.
Unfassbar bekloppt wie kann man nur so ein Messegelände hinbauen also ein Ort,
ja davon lebt dass du Fläche vermietest ja unter und dann nutze deine Flächen nicht so.
Baust dir auch noch relativ teuer außer das war jetzt eure nicht nicht wird jetzt nicht besonders günstig also nicht,
keine Elbphilharmonie so ja aber wird schon so ein bisschen Geld gekostet haben aber der höhere Preis den du zahlst ist eigentlich derjenige dass du eben diese Fläche nicht wirklich effektiv nutzen kann,
wie sich das z.b. bei unserem Kongress zeigt ne,
wird das Ding z.b. konsequent warm weil irgendwie,
doppelverglast und halt irgendwie richtig geschlossen oder zu müssen definiert öffnen fähig Fußbodenheizung entsprechen die Isolierung am Boden irgendwas um einfach,
da sind thermisches Konzept hinzulegen wie läuft man eben mit mit,
Bedingung bei niedrigen Temperaturen das Heizen kann.
Bzw ist auch entsprechend klimatisieren kann wenn es heiß drauf prasselt,
dann kannst du das halt irgendwie wunderbar nutzen ist ja gerade das bei uns beim Kongress das Problem ist ja im Prinzip so,
festgenagelt sind einerseits auf das CCL was an sich ganz gut wäre warum ist es halt einfach mal per 3 oder vervierfachen sein Größe dann wäre es für unsere Zwecke halt optimal müsste man halt so auf,
planum wie jede Richtung verdoppeln dann dann wäre es halt perfekt oder du nutzt halt dann.
Die Messehallen wir es jetzt halt machen müssen nur die Messehallen, da irgendwie mit 40000 Quadratmeter her sind halt einfach mal fett.
Unten und 20.000 durcheinander,
auf jeden Fall ziemlich groß ist aufgewacht verdammte groß und,
ja dann hast du halt diese Glashalle dir ist auch noch dazwischen genutzten Hallen liegt also als Verbinder Bau,
kannst aber halt nicht richtig irgendwie nice was machen oder irgendwann mal zu einem RoboCup.
Da hatten sie irgendwie in den Hallen halt ihr diese.
RoboCup Spiele gemacht und unten paar Felder war noch in der Glas Wurst.
Aber es war unerträglich niemand ist da rein gegangen weil es war hat Sommerzeit da die Sonne drauf gestanden haben,
uns halt auch akustisch als schwierig nach alles total zerfressen wird akustisch und dass das halt auch sowas was ich irgendwie nicht verstehen kann.
Spielwiese acoustic von so großen Verkehrs.
Bahnhöfe oder was auch immer als Wetter in Zürich waren ja auch ein relativ opulenter Flughafen und gerade so einen großen Abflughalle auch wenn da irgendwie 100 Leute umher woozle und sich unterhalten das ist.
Ultra leise ist mir sehr stark aufgefallen und genauer ebenso Hauptbahnhof oder diese Glas was kann ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen ist dann eben genau das Gegenteil aber wie gesagt ich will das jetzt auch noch gar nicht so.
Besonders jetzt negativ oder so sehen soll ich bin einfach mal gespannt was dann da draus so wird und wie der kreative Umgang eben mit dem Medium passiert und was ich dafür Lösung 1.
Aber was ich für Lösung dazu präsentieren für die ganzen Probleme.
Altern letzten Besuch meinte ich halt irgendwie ziemlich einfach wegklopfen und was ordentliches hinbauen wollen sollst mich immer etwas verstört an komisch ne Wurst.
Ja das hatte als Deckert auch so einen großen 1 zu 50 Modell irgendwie wahrscheinlich den vorgeführt haben sie gesehen Beschicker Glaskasten und dann,
Martin Otto bitte das ist ein Neunzigern hasse es einfach aus einer autocut library rausgezogen und wieso liefert alles ist so sieht doch der alles aus was neu angebaut wurde sie ganz merkwürdig,
einfachen Geometrien die da irgendwie überall waren ne.
Aber zum anderen was ich auch interessant fand das die Hallen ja auch um mir immer so ein Fenster Ring ringsrum haben also muss man natürlich einiges wahrscheinlich einen malt on um die Lichtschein Nerds,
durchgehend an der Seite bist du sicher nicht auf dieser Fototour war viel Licht in den Hallen wo hast du denn diese Fototour,
von oben weiß nicht ob die öffentlich ist wenn es nicht so ganz un können wir dir aber bestimmt mal zu wenig mal wenig mal,
ich dachte mir dann halt so heute nicht sowieso hier und da immer sowieso Fensterflächen willhaben hat zumindest könnte man den Kongress wahrscheinlich schon von weitem sehen wenn dann aus allen,
irgendwie so die Lichter so rausschneiden und buntes Raumschiff wird dann am Ende,
aber mal gucken wie gesagt wir schon meinte ich habe erstmal keine großen Erwartungen sondern.
Bin die sollen die müssen eigentlich die Wurst wegknallen.
Finde die universelle Wahrheit dieser Sendung die Mütze,
immer diese Perspektive Eingang ist oder trotzdem noch hin aber Wasser Wasser an Platz verschwendet wird was du dafür geile Vortragssäle mit reinbauen für Zucker sind zwei dicke fette,
Vortragssäle machen und dann brauchst du irgendwie alles schick also also jeder die Möglichkeit tatsächlich,
das ist das wo ich wahrscheinlich jetzt zu Hause komplett nur aus der Außensicht so auch mal Kopf kratzen und mit Fragezeichen im Kopf auf die zu gehen würde und so,
also das sind jetzt eure Vortrags und Seminare man sie sind ja da manche aus wie wirklich irgendwie.
Bunker Räume und also diese kleineren Vortragsräume was jetzt dazwischen.
Nee die sind alles okay aus aber wieso träume die Ultra hohe Decken haben relativ schmal,
verstehen irgendwie was ich 20-30 nähwaren vielleicht 50-60 Stühle drinnen und um mir alles so sehr komisch geschnitten und eng und,
müssen alles nur zwei die zwei Vortrag Serien die sind relativ worden also die Seele ganz ehrlich alles was im CCL ist es super,
es ist TTL fishcop so Messehallen sind Messehallen aber die Seele sind ja auch nicht groß genug oder also ich habe schon eine Leiche nicht für uns,
sie werden hat sich genutzt aber sind der große Anteil 1000 das ist auf dem Standardname 14 Jahren.
Sofern seid gespannt was euch da erwartet wird was anderes als in Hamburg sein,
vielleicht noch ein Wort zum Sendezentrum jetzt mal glaube ich nicht erwähnt.
Sendezentrum wird diesmal nur in kleiner Form klassischer Form geben also es wird ein Ort geben wo man,
mit Podcast an andocken kann Sendezentrum wird wahrscheinlich im CCL,
sein und da auf Ebene 1.
Es wird aber keine Bühne geben wie in den letzten Jahren das hat.
Viele Gründe vor allem denen das ist dieses Jahr für unsere Community einfach unser Tore schlägt nicht zu leisten war das zu tun und davon abgesehen,
denke ich mal ist auch ganz gut da mal auszusetzen und sich auch mal ein bisschen selber zu finden und auch mal selber noch mal.
Klar zu machen was man da eigentlich zu transportieren will also ob man da irgendwie jetzt nur noch so eine V Bühne des Kongresses wird oder dann doch irgendwas eigenes.
Wirklich anzubieten hat Wasser neben auch wirklich außer Computer herauskommt.
Bitte ganz gespannt wie sich so bestimmte assemblies dort entwickeln werden insbesondere wieder sich in der großen Messehalle da in the Hive.
Sehr heiß und die Zusammenballung so ein riesen hat Center im Prinzip diesmal also da bin ich echt am meisten gespannt was dabei rauskommt das wird bestimmt.
Das wird das dass das größte? Für mich so denn der Rest im CCL da manchmal ich überhaupt gar keine Sorgen.
Aber wie wie das ankommt und wie die Vortragssäle an ankommen werden das.
Weiß ich nicht aber wir sagt Sendezentrum im CCL ist da aber.
Ohne große Bühne es gibt aber ein oder zwei oder Podcaster sende Tische wo also Sendung gesendet werden können dann die meisten Slots auch schon verplant aber ein paar sind vielleicht noch zu haben ist ja mal gucken wenn ihr noch Interesse habt selber Nintendo machen wollt.
Fondskongress bitten wir die Infrastruktur das zu tun aber halt keine dicken fetten Schoß.
Dementsprechend gibt es auch keine Freakshow und keine.
Kein Logbuch Netzpolitik und kein NSFW und auch sonst nichts von der Metaebene ich setze dieses Jahr mal komplett aus mit Produktion.
So okay ja ist auch dringend ich schau mal.
Ja habe ich mal hörertreffen interglas Wurst und fertig schnell Glasrosen bei McDonald's in der Rutsche.
Man könnte aus der Wurst ein riesiges Bällebad machen das würde für die Akustik wahrscheinlich auch Fotodesignerin machen einfach so viel Party bis warm wird.
Die Lounge lass dich überraschen schnell kann es geschehen.
Sommer fertig oder wat fix und fertig kurze Sendung zu kurz oder,
Badran Absturz auch reichen einhalb Stunden Bitcoin und danach eine halbe Stunde.
Na übertreibe natürlich ein kleines bisschen ja kommt aber nur ein bisschen viele viele viele viele Investoren.
Warten auf diese Botschaft auf diese Hintergrundinformationen und darauf verwettet wie der Kurs steigen wird oder nicht.
Lach ich will nicht sagen dass er da kann er nur müde lächeln,
noch nicht so lange,
erstmal die rumheulen Verkauf Saher auf Dennis hören heißt siegen lernen also das auf jeden Fall schon mal festhalten.
Betty seitdem ich je einen Tipp geben sollte welchen rum ich bitte zu Hause behalten soll ich werde es mir merken.
Habe ich keinen Tipp meine Tipps immer noch verändern von anderen müssen wir sowieso nicht ab,
ich interpretiere die dann durch Wurst die sozusagen und mache Scheiße und wenn die sagen ja der ist voll super die musste voll saufen dann gucke ich gesagt ja das war super Ball genau den den trinkst du nicht den hierzu auf,
schreib mir merken genau in diesem Sinne so gab es auch welche wichtigen Botschaften bevor wir uns ja schalten.
Welche Dinge subliminale Botschaften nein.
Wünsche fürs neue Jahr Sonne Pakete die wir noch nicht aufgemacht haben nur.
Das für Clemens.
Da ist noch ein Stück nicht mit ja das hat er letzte Mal nicht mitgenommen dass ich dir schon lange Segelboot nächstes Jahr live from Mittelmeer,
bewährt meine Herausforderung auf jeden Fall und dann gibt's auch 220 Volt klar.
Navigation anzeigen Marina dann im Zweifel nur ne aber man braucht ja auch Netz für den stream.
Jan küsst mir geht das schon so gar nicht live Richtung verlegen und macht uns dabei 12 Volt Akku stimmt was,
sofern bis handy akku laden halt mit Solar oder nein oder wie, es gibt da schon zwei Batterien einmal die für den Motoren Pärchen und dann für Baustrom und den kann man dann auch mal für die paar Stunden.
Ordentlich habe sogar noch eine Ahnung,
Otto oder was auch immer manche Boote haben manche haben auch einen extra Stromgenerator tatsächlich für Diesel.
Also Diesel Stromgenerator.
Starte ich den passenden Akku noch hier in der Kiste und warum liegen na wunderbar dann kann das ja stattfinden.
Na du mit 12 Volt 5 Volt und so halt schon so ein bisschen.
Ja das kriegen wir schon hin und ich meine deinen Audio Setup dein mobiles ist das nicht eben mit so einem Zoom Recorder.
Musst du brauchst du denn noch viel Strom Kopfhörerverstärker und ja auch nicht so mega viel oder.
Moers wir wollten alles hin,
also freuen uns auf eure Spenden für die Friedhof auf dem Boot,
dauerspende jetzt kaufen Sie jetzt ihre Weihnachtsgeschenke über Amazon Metaebene Leute.
Wir bedanken uns für eure Beteiligung an diesem Freakshow ja.
Wünschen euch einen schönen Kongress und welche,
religiösen Festivitäten sich sonst für euch dann noch drumherum fahren oder auch nicht.
Und dann musst auf Kongress nicht treffen natürlich auch noch ein frohes neues Jahr.
Tolles auch erfolgreich mit steigenden Bitcoin Kursen die anderen Kurse dürfen mittlerweile auch gehen dann die freecall noch raus und dann.
So wie das gerade alle machen Berge da war noch einfach nur zeigen dass es geht so schlimm ist es funktioniert.
Bereich Gefahr irgendwie fork drücken und fertig einfach.
Music.
Falls jemand von der Verwaltung der Piep das war's tschüss bis bald und tschüss.